[Musik]
willkommen zu zdf heute live wie geht es
weiter in der panini jetzt da omikron
sicher schon seit geraumer zeit doch
ziemlich rasant bei uns ausbreitet wird
es verschärfungen geben wird es
vielleicht sogar lockerungen geben oder
bleibt alles im wesentlichen so wie es
derzeit ist diese frage beantwortet die
bund länder runde die seit dem frühen
nachmittag zusammensitzt und die im
hoffentlich nicht allzu ferner zukunft
dann auch eine pressekonferenz abhalten
wird ihr seht im hintergrund das podium
da tut sich noch nicht so viel kann ich
euch jetzt schon verraten aber wir sind
natürlich dann live drauf sobald ist da
los geht unter anderem der bundeskanzler
olaf scholz wird sich dort zu wort
melden darauf warten wir also und wir
sprechen zu diesem thema aber auch mit
folgenden gästen nämlich mit professor
hc vom leibniz-institut für präventiv
forschung und epidemiologie außerdem mit
unserer hauptstadt korrespondent in
nicole diekmann und mit fabian radix
geschäftsführer von labor berlin europas
größtem krankenhaus labor
tochterunternehmen der charité also ich
denke da kriegen wir einige ganz gute
informationen und erkenntnisse geboten
und auch natürlich wie immer an euch der
aufruf gerne eure fragen und kommentare
an uns zu schicken zunächst aber nach
berlin zu meiner kolleginnen nicole
diekmann und da ist ja auch schon die
callya ab mit welchen ergebnissen
rechnest du denn für die heutige runde
und warum dauert das dann schon wieder
so lange es ist ja schon wieder man den
eindruck einiges was diskutiert werden
muss
naja also wenn man mal auf die zahlen
blickt die schnellen ja in die höhe
werte wie nie jeder tag ein rekord und
zwar kein rekord über die man sich freut
sondern ein schwieriger rekord die
impedanz so hoch wie nie die
die zahlen der neuinfektionen so hoch
wie nie das allein gebe ja schon grund
heute länger zu sprechen und hinzu kommt
eine vertrackte lage denn
die frage hast du ja eben schon gestellt
kommt es zu verschärfungen oder kommt es
gar zu lockerungen wir haben auch heute
wieder eine beschlussvorlage
und haben die ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten heute natürlich auch
und da ist ganz interessant dass bereits
im zweiten punkt dieser beschlussvorlage
verlagert hat er nicht festgehalten wird
dass sobald sich die situation in den
krankenhäusern
entspannt oder absehbar ist dass es
nicht wieder so schlimm wird wie unter
delta denn im moment sieht es danach aus
dass omikron zumindest für die
krankenhäuser für die intensivstation
nicht so furchtbar wird für die
situation dort die delta dann könnte man
natürlich darüber reden müsse man auch
darüber reden wir schüsse zurückzunehmen
in punkt eins jedoch dieser
beschlussvorlage die ich hier auch vor
mir liegen habe wird auch noch mal
darauf hingewiesen
dass die bisherigen maßnahmen
fortgesetzt werden das heißt unterm
strich es ist heute nicht mit
verschärfungen zu rechnen es ist auch
nicht mit lockerungen zu rechnen und
deswegen finde ich persönlich jetzt am
interessantesten gleich mit blick auf
die pressekonferenz werden ab welchem
schwerpunktsetzung wird geht es gleich
darum so sagen passt auf liebe leute
wenn es so bleibt wenn es ein bisschen
einfacher wird wenn sich die bisherigen
eindrücke von omikron bewahrheiten dann
reden wir demnächst tatsächlich darüber
was wir wieder zurücknehmen oder ob es
eher eine mahnung die pressekonferenz
wird eine sehr vorsichtige
pressekonferenz mit dem tenor wir sind
noch nicht am scheitelpunkt das soll ja
erst mitte februar der fall sein sagt
der bundesgesundheitsminister wir
bleiben vorsichtig und machen erstmal so
weiter wie bisher ja in der tat eine
spannende frage du hast jetzt die
beschlussvorlage schon mehrfach
angesprochen wir beide kennen sie unser
publikum vielleicht noch nicht und
deswegen würde ich gerne noch mal so
eine allgemeine gesprächsgrundlage
schaffen mein kollege andreas huppert
derzeit noch mal um was es da im
wesentlichen geht in einem
beschlussvorschlag ist man sich im
vorfeld allerdings schon einig die
bisher geltenden regeln sollen bestehen
bleiben das bestätigt auch der
bundesgesundheitsminister im zdf
interview
das ist ja bekannt dass deutschland
gemessen an der bevölkerung und auch am
alter der bevölkerung die zweitälteste
bevölkerung in europa sehr wenige
todesfälle beklagen musste im vergleich
das ist etwas was ich richtig finde und
das braucht natürlich eine sehr
vorsichtigen kurs dabei bleiben wir erst
in dem moment in dem man ausschließen
kann dass die gesundheitssysteme
überbelastet sind will man über öffnungs
perspektiven nachdenken auch das steht
in der beschlussvorlage wenn wir das
hinter uns haben dann kann es bei den
einschränkungen natürlich nicht bleiben
und dann wurde man schritt für schritt
wurde man wieder hoffnungen machen das
jetzt schon ins auge zu fassen ist
richtig schon jetzt überlastet die
laborkapazitäten auch die pcr tests sind
mittlerweile mangelware daher will die
mpk nur noch chronisch kranken oder dem
personal in kliniken und
pflegeeinrichtungen die möglichkeit
dieser testung zugänglich machen
tja greift vielleicht gerade den letzten
punkt der angesprochen wurde da nochmal
auf also die knappheit der test
kapazitäten der pcr tests das ist ein
punkt der bei vielen auf doch relativ
großes unverständnis stößt denn die
knappheit bzw der bedarf an tests der
war ja nun irgendwie nicht ganz
unerwartet wie angreifbar macht sich da
die bundesregierung aus seiner sicht
beziehungsweise auch der minister
ja das ist ja das alte lied muss man
fast schon sagen und das ist kein sehr
lustiges lied die knappheit haben wir
auch schon gesehen beim thema machten
deswegen gab es ja zunächst keine
machten pflicht weil nicht genug machten
da waren und dasselbe wiederholte sich
später beim impfstoff erinnern uns wie
bitterlich wir alle auf einen impftermin
gewartet haben und bin ich wir alle
sagen dann gucken wir auch noch mal auch
die wohlhabenden gruppen die ja damals
priorität hatten also die besonders
älteren leute und vor erkrankte der
mangel ist ein roter faden der sich
durch diese pandemie zieht hier in
deutschland jetzt sind es also die pcr
tests und
da kann man natürlich auf der einen
seite sagen
diese regierung ist noch frisch im abend
relativ die ist in der letzten jahres
erst vereidigt worden in person karl
lauterbach ist noch nicht so lange
bundesgesundheitsminister auf der
anderen seite kommt diese knappheit ja
dann anscheinend doch wieder
überraschend und das pfund mit dem er
wuchern und zwar zu recht nämlich vom
fach zu sein als epidemiologe das nimmt
dann natürlich doch leichten schaden
denn man hätte das womöglich voraussehen
können alex zog schack fragt uns über
youtube ich habe irgendwie gehört dass
es eine pcr-test pflicht geben wird
stimmt das habe ich jetzt so nicht gäbe
wäre dann auch schwierig angesichts der
problematik mit den mangel nimmt
na ja also ich würde es jetzt nicht
ausschließen es wäre nicht das erste
unlogische moment in dieser pandemie
aber das wäre halt komplett unlogisch da
würde man sich ja ins eigene knie
schießen zu sagen wir etablieren jetzt
einen pcr-test pflicht und dann blank
ziehen zu müssen uns so sagen wir haben
aber gar keine das wäre ja
offenbarungseid mit
betonung auf offenbar und denn dann wäre
es sehr augenscheinlich wieder knapp die
pcr test kapazitäten gerade sind also
das aber gebe es gerade noch mal durch
also angesichts dieser knappheit für wen
sollen die pcr tests jetzt seines
wissens nach in erster linie vorgehalten
werden
obwohl der radler gruppen ich gucke noch
mehr gerade in die beschlussvorlage
honorable gruppen steht da und
beschäftigte die diese betreuen und
verhandeln auch viel sollen sich jetzt
die pcr test kapazitäten in zukunft
konzentrieren das heißt also kranker
menschen die
sterben könnten potenziell wenn sie sich
mit corona infizieren und leute wie zum
beispiel krankenpfleger
krankenpflegerinnen ärztin
beschäftigte in pflege- und altersheimen
so lese ich dass ein anderer wunder
punkt muss man sagen ist die reduzierung
des genesenen status so verkündete ja
vom robert-koch-institut auf drei monate
jetzt von dem wurden viele betroffene
relativ kalt überrascht und was man so
hört ist das auch ein knackpunkt jetzt
bei den bund länder gesprächen da sind
nämlich auch viele aus den ländern gar
nicht begeistert gewesen wie das ablief
was ist da zu hören auch da glaube ich
ist der bundesgesundheitsminister in der
kritik wenn ich das richtig verstehe
da ist der bundesgesundheitsminister in
der kritik und jetzt lese ich mal punkt
6 aus dieser beschlussvorlage vor das
ist nämlich die hohe kunst des
diplomatischen politischen handelns und
formulieren es unter punkt 6 steht ihr
genesenen und im status die
regierungschefin und regierungschefs der
länder begrüßen dass der bundesminister
für gesundheit angekündigt hat dass die
nach der geänderten cupid 19
schutzmaßnahmen ausnahmen verordnung vom
paul-ehrlich-institut und robert koch
institut zu treffenden festlegungen zum
geimpften und genesenen status aufgrund
ihrer erheblichen reichweite achtung
künftig rechtzeitig vor ihrem
inkrafttreten angekündigt und begründet
werden das heißt das macht der karl
lauterbach so nicht noch mal und wir
freuen uns dass es so nicht noch mal
gemacht wird das ist sehr geschickt
verhohlener ärger darüber dass das
jemand sagen über nacht passiert ist und
viele tatsächlich sehr überrascht hat ja
ja also soll das nicht auch mal machen
das ist deutlich geworden so jedenfalls
die auffassung die dort in diesem
gremium vor herrscht und man kann es ja
auch nachvollziehen wie gesagt auch
viele betroffene waren davon nicht
begeistert dass es über nacht quasi so
gekommen ist ein anderer dauerbrenner
sozusagen in der gesamten diskussion ist
das thema impfpflicht was ist denn zu
diesem erfreulichen thema nach außen
gedrungen beziehungsweise was wird
momentan diskutiert da gibt es ja auch
noch mal die unterscheidung die
allgemeine natürlich aber auch die
daneben für fachpersonal was ist dazu zu
sagen
na ja die für fachpersonal im
fachjargon heißt es die einrichtungs
bezogene impfpflicht das sind ja quasi
dieselben leute die das betrifft die ich
gerade eben genannt habe die priorität
haben sollen künftig für pcr tests also
menschen die in pflege und altenheimen
arbeiten in krankenhäusern die ist ja
geschlossen die soll ab märz in kraft
treten
dann gibt es eben die allgemeine
impfpflicht die diskutiert wird auf die
wirtin dieser beschlussvorlage noch mal
hingewiesen für die wirtin dieser
beschlussvorlage nochmal geworben aber
das große aber diese impfpflicht ist
tatsächlich heiß diskutiert man biete es
daran dass sich die bundesregierung
ja manche sagen da verdrückt ich komme
gleich darauf warum man sagt drückt
einen eigenen gesetzentwurf vorzulegen
und zwar ist die vermutung derer die
davon drücken reden dass die ampel
bestehend aus spd grünen und fdp das
nicht tut weil man nicht sicher sein
kann ob man eine mehrheit
zusammenbekommt ist gibt ja in dieser
woche wird zum ersten mal diskutiert im
bundestag übermorgen über eine geplante
impfpflicht es gibt ja aus den reihen
der fdp allen voran wolfgang kubicki
eine gruppe die wie kubicki sagt aus
immerhin einem drittel der fdp
abgeordneten besteht die einen entwurf
einbringen will gegen die impfpflicht
der dem sich soeben
fraktionsübergreifend jetzt abgestimmt
werden auch angehörige anderer
bundestagsfraktionen anderer parteien
anschließen können es gibt jetzt auch
die idee über eine impfpflicht erst ab
einem gewissen alter zu diskutieren also
das heißt man ist sich in den parteien
selber auch überhaupt nicht einig wie
gesagt vor allem die fdp hatte große
schwierigkeiten eine meinung unter einen
hut zu bekommen und dass deswegen oder
daran sieht man wie umstritten dieses
thema ist ja in der tat umstritten ich
gucke gerade noch mal auf meinen
spickzettel was eben die maßnahmen
angeht die da jetzt eben gerade zur
debatte stehen also die laut
beschlussvorlage im wesentlichen ist es
ja schon gesagt zu bleiben sollen wie
sie sind im pflicht hat mir gerade
angesprochen die öffnungs perspektiven
die werden ja nun auch schon von dem
einen oder anderen verlangt dass
zumindest für den tag an dem sich dann
doch die zahlen wieder einigermaßen
absenken das kann allerdings noch wochen
dauern
und herr lauterbach hatte glaube ich
mitte februar als den kulminationspunkt
sozusagen angepeilt trotzdem fordern
manche dass dafür jetzt auch schon ein
klares szenario entwickelt werden soll
wenn ich das so richtig weiß
genau das ist zum einen natürlich
psychologie wir sind alle müde wir sind
alle genervt wir sind alle frustriert es
ist kalt draußen es ist also wenig leben
möglich gerade ohne die beschränkungen
die gerade bestehen und wir nähern uns
dem pandemie 3 da ist es natürlich
psychologische auch von öffnungs
perspektiven in diesem papier zu reden
zu schreiben die leute das lesen zu
lassen dann gibt es einen nächsten
wichtigen punkt interessanterweise
gehört ja auch markus söder der
bayerische ministerpräsident zu
denjenigen die sagen wir müssen jetzt
auch mal mit augenmaß agieren also team
vorsicht war bisher jetzt scheint das
team augen macht zu sein dem er sich
selber
zuordnet und ich sage mal so
markus söder hatte schon bessere
umfragewerte eventuell besteht da ein
zusammenhang ja und dann wiederum gibt
es auch stimmen aus der fdp die ich ja
eben schon angesprochen habe die auch
sagen wir müssen ein stück zurück zur
normalität
noch mal die fdp ist da in sich
zerrissen die fdp war im wahlkampf bevor
sie in regierungsverantwortung kam
sehr kritisch den corona maßnahmen
gegenüber die damals noch regierende
gruppe
vorgestellt hat und auf mpk es dann auch
tja in die beschlüsse die beschluss
pipeline geschickt hat um es mal so zu
formulieren die fdp hatte einen sehr
weiten weg zurückgelegt schon das muss
man sagen und es gibt eben nach wie vor
innerhalb der fdp diejenigen die das was
im moment praktiziert wird für nicht
angemessen und auch für problematisch im
einklang mit dem grundgesetz zu bringen
halten ich lese gerade noch mal ein paar
kommentare vor an dieser stelle
über youtube bbc schreibt wann kommt
endlich die impfpflicht dank der korona
leugner geht die pandemie endlos weiter
über die impfpflicht haben wir gerade
schon gesprochen ein schwieriges thema
markus rüdiger nieder über facebook
sorry aber die muppet show bringt mehr
effektive maßnahmen zusammen also ein
durchaus kritischer kommentar was die
effektivität unseres regierungshandeln
angeht okay dass seine meinung nicole
ich danke dir für den moment wir würden
gerne die runde nochmal erweitern um
fabian raddatz ich habe es schon
angesprochen er ist geschäftsführer von
labor berlin europas größten krankenhaus
labor und auch gleichzeitig
tochterunternehmen der charité und da
sehe ich ihn auch schon hallo herr
raddatz schön dass sie die zeit haben
einen schönen abend
hätte wäre man sehr gerne
fragen wir doch mal nach sozusagen in
der praxis also sie haben ja denn ein
blick dann auch eben in die labore und
wie haben sie schon gehört die test
kapazitäten sind knapp bemessen wie
dramatisch sehen sie die situation im
moment
also ich sehe die situation mit großer
sorge und wir sind hier weil air berlin
sicherlich repräsentativ für im grunde
genommen jedes andere labor in ganz
deutschland ja wir haben es zu tun mit
stetig anwachsenden anforderungen an die
korona tcr und gleichzeitig natürlich
mit einer so auch noch nie dagewesenen
unwägbarkeit was unsere eigene
personaldecke angeht weil unsere
kolleginnen und kollegen sind natürlich
dann auch von infektionen betroffen mit
anschließender isolation oder auch von
quarantäne situationen und insofern
haben wir schon große hoffnung jetzt in
die beschlüsse auch der mpk gehabt und
dann das was dann in der umsetzung kommt
und das müssen wir jetzt natürlich wenn
es eine rechtzeitige wirkung erzielen
soll auch jetzt demnächst alsbald und so
kurzfristig wie irgendwie möglich
passieren damit mögliche maßnahmen nicht
erst kommen wenn die welle
möglicherweise auch sich das gebäude
welche konkreten beschlüsse haben sie
sich dann erhofft oder erhoffen sie sich
also das hängt davon ab was da jetzt
tatsächlich kommt wenn wir uns die
beschlussvorlage von gestern angucken
wie sie ja auch von gerade beleuchtet
haben dann ist das sicherlich ein
schritt in die richtige richtung und das
ist natürlich auch absolut positiv zu
bewerten dass die politik jetzt auf
bundes und landesebene sich intensiv mit
apricot wesentlichen fragen beschäftigt
aus der vogelperspektive eben mit der
frage wie gehen wir jetzt mit
limitierten test kapazitäten um die wut
reagiert auf der anderen seite ist der
wortlaut dieser beschlussvorlage die wir
gestern zumindest gesehen haben
natürlich hinsichtlich des detailgrad
ist noch
noch nicht so dass wir daraus ableiten
können dass es in den laboren in
deutschland denn tatsächlich auf dieser
basis zu einer spürbaren auswirkung
kommt also da müssen wir tatsächlich
dann hoffen dass da konkrete
formulierung reinkommen und
die ppr tests dann beispielsweise
wirklich erstmal nur für dringende
medizinische fragen eingesetzt werden
das betrifft die patienten mit klarem
medizinischen indikation und auch dem
risiko eines schweren verlauf und dann
muss eben auch irgendwo festgestellt
werden im besten fall dass die ppr
testung zur bestätigung eines positiven
schafkopf zwei anti g schnelltests
beispielsweise dann irgendwas gehend
ausgesetzt wird ja ich nehme mal ein
beispiel wenn sie eine gebuchte
testperson haben also jemand der die die
dritte auffrischimpfung erhalten hat und
jetzt leichte symptome hat und daneben
einen positiven antigen schnelltest dann
halte ich das für nicht erforderlich
dass so eine situation die pcr test
bestätigt wird übrigens unabhängig davon
ob die betreffende person im
gesundheitswesen arbeitet oder in einem
anderen sektor ja sie haben also gerade
die problematik gut beschrieben die
laborarbeiten also am limit um die pcr
tests ausreichend schnell auszuwerten
wir wollen aber den blick so zu sagen
weil über die landesgrenze hinaus weiten
hat deutschland vielleicht es auch
versäumt da die passende strategie zu
entwickeln die frage stellt sich ja denn
andere länder österreich zum beispiel
machen es anders und mehr dazu hat jetzt
constanze kainz bzw von sat 1 zusammen
mit eva schiller das gucken uns jetzt
auch normal
wieder eine neue lieferung wieder boxen
voll mit abstrichen wieder mehr pcr
tests zwölf mitarbeiter wurden hier im
ludwigsburger labor geschult um tests zu
analysieren sie machen überstunden und
kaum urlaub weil personal fehlt während
die korona zahlen explodieren
sie müssen sich vorstand dass die die
instanzen dadurch zustande kommen dass
tests gemacht werden ja und daraus
ergibt sich das ja schon dass bei uns
einfach das gruppe aufkommen deutlich
höher ist und das muss das personal
puppen und wir müssen einfach das tun
was notwendig ist und gegebenenfalls
wird dann halt test länger brauchen aber
der kampf gegen omikron ist auch ein
kampf gegen die zeit und wo schnelltests
an grenzen stoßen sind schnelle pcr
ergebnisse umso wichtiger hätte
deutschland besser vorbereitet sein
müssen in wien fährt man seit 2020 eine
komplett andere test strategie man setzt
auf kostenlose pcr tests gurgeln zu
hause das video zur kontrolle hochladen
die probe abgeben im supermarkt mehrmals
pro woche testen sich so kinder und
erwachsene in firmen behörden kliniken
extra für corona eingerichtete riesen
labore werden pro woche mehr als 3,5
millionen pcr tests aus mehr als ganz
deutschland zusammen die erkannten fälle
sind dementsprechend hoch aber dadurch
können infektionen früh erkannt die
versionen können früher eine absonderung
geschickt werden damit werden
infektionsketten noch vor unterbrochen
wissenschaftler der uni wien haben die
pcr strategie entwickelt sie auch dem rk
ii vorgeführt eine verpasste chance sagt
michael wagner ich glaube deutschland
hat es zu lange aus einer rein
medizinisch diagnostischen perspektive
engagiert wie perfekt ist der test dabei
übersehen dass die pcr auch mit google
und polen um grössenordnungen
empfindlicher ist als jäger antigen test
und auch ganz leicht angepasst werden
kann an neujahr in deutschland versucht
irgendwie ohne strategie test
kapazitäten hoch zu schrauben pcr test
sollen sparsamer eingesetzt
gesundheitspersonal priorisiert werden
wien macht das genaue gegenteil pcr
tests für alle rund um die uhr das labor
hat die kapazitäten auf 800.000 tests
pro tag aufgestockt
800.000 pro tag das ist natürlich eine
hausnummer herr raddatz vermissen sie
eine strategie der bundesregierung
beziehungsweise sind sie der ansicht
dass man hierzulande eine falsche
verfolgt wie gucken sie nach österreich
also ich bin sehr dankbar für diesen
beitrag und auch für die frage die hier
auf geworden wird und ich möchte mir
nicht anmaßen über falsche politische
entscheidung zu urteilen ich habe
allerdings die große sorge dass wir hier
möglicherweise äpfel mit birnen
vergleichen ja wenn wir jetzt die test
zahlen in österreich und deutschland
vergleichen bei uns werden seit wochen
und monaten tatsächliche tests zahlen im
wortsinne reported und erhoben und zwar
unabhängig davon wie viele pool testung
der regional auch bei uns sehr intensiv
im hintergrund stattfinden ja das heißt
wir zählen ein test auch dann wenn in
diesem pool test möglicherweise zehn
personen beispielsweise enthalten sind
in österreich werden meines wissens die
testpersonen gefehlt hätten sie in
meinem beispiel fall in österreich 10
und in deutschland ein
ich würde gerne tatsächlich auch die
frage aufwerfen warum die uns so
intensiv mit der mit der herausforderung
steigerung der test kapazitäten
beschäftigen und was das eigentlich
bringen soll ja denn wenn wir uns eine
andere statistik noch mal widmen und uns
die paneele bilanz hier anschauen in
deutschland dann
schneiden wir sehr gut ab im
ländervergleich auch sozusagen im
vergleich mit österreicher wir haben
hier in deutschland weniger fälle
absolut als beispiel zu einem
österreicher haben eine niedrigere in
frieden als in österreich und warum ist
das so dass liegt meines erachtens daran
dass das testen an sich nicht ursächlich
ist für eine hohe oder niedrige incident
und da kommen wir wieder auf
das alte credo zurück ich weiß dass
bisher stark strapaziert ist aber
trotzdem wenn wir die pandemie in den
griff bekommen in kriegen jetzt mit
testen hin sondern wir müssen uns an die
regeln halten an das lüften und
möglichst viele personen müssen das
impfangebot war nicht ja das ist
unbestritten also möglichst viele leute
müssen sich impfen lassen
andererseits würde ich trotzdem gerne
noch mal bei den tests bleiben denn es
ist ja schon augenfällig wir haben ja
eingangs darüber gesprochen es fehlt
jetzt halt eben dann doch an test
kapazitäten an pcr test ist das nicht
ein ja doch ein problem das vermeidbar
gewesen wäre also ich meine wie
beurteilen sie das
also ich kann ihnen keine auskunft geben
über gewordenen politischen
entscheidungen ich kann ihnen allerdings
und einblick geben in die
lebenswirklichkeit der deutschen labore
und dass das in den letzten monaten sei
panini beginn passiert ist und dann
können wir ein festhalten und da sind
wir sicherlich wieder so präsent aktiv
für die gesamte labor landschaft in
deutschland wir haben eigeninitiativ auf
eigene verantwortung lebens auf eigene
kosten innerhalb kürzester zeit eine
erhebliche skalierung in der kapazität
hinbekommen ja das ist geräte seitlich
passiert material seitig und
selbstverständlich das ist das
wichtigste dabei mit blick auf das
qualifizierte fachpersonal satz die
ppr-kreuzung in den laboren durchführt
auch wenn sie sich die zahlen jetzt auch
den letzten wochen noch mal anschauen
dann wählen die das alleine sozusagen
von der kw 2 auch die kab drei jetzt
sicherlich wieder eine steigerung der
kapazität von oberhalb 10 prozent
jeweils gegenüber der vorwoche
vorgenommen wurde das ist das was wir
hier in der moorlandschaft getan haben
und unsere teams arbeiten seit zwei
jahren mittlerweile am anschlag
also ich versuche jetzt immer noch raus
zu hören ob sie mit der gegenwärtigen
situation eher zufrieden oder eher
unzufrieden sind
während ich mir nach wir stecken im
moment so tief in einer akuten situation
wir müssen als labor hier den kopf über
wasser erhalten so dass ich mir nicht
anmaßen möchte über politische
versäumnisse potenziell verurteilen er
verstehe befürchten sie dann eine
weitere verschärfung der situation auch
des mangels an tests
also was wir sehen ist im moment dass
wir systemseitig wohl gut aufgestellt
sind material seit ich also mit blick
auf die frage haben wir das nötige
verbrauchsmaterial die reagenzien die
chemikalien für die ppr testung wie ich
im moment noch eine relativ gute
situation die große unwägbarkeit ist
eben das personal das qualifizierte
person in unseren laboren als
limitierender faktor und da ganz ehrlich
haben wir ja sozusagen eine qualität der
unwägbarkeit die dir so auch noch nicht
erlebt haben sie können sich sicher sein
dass alle labore in deutschland
natürlich überaus fall pläne verfügen
ihr und rechtzeitig gedanken darüber
gemacht haben wo kompensiert werden kann
wenn personal ausfällt und auch wo in
den einzelnen labor bereichen dann
diagnostik vielleicht auch
zurückgestellt werden kann auf basis der
kriterien wichtigkeit und dringlichkeit
allerdings sehe ich die aktuelle
situation tatsächlich eine große rolle
weil wir eben auch nicht unbegrenzt
kompensation mechanismen im hintergrund
haben herr raddatz eine letzte frage
auch wenn sie jetzt die politik nicht
bewerten wollen das kann ich
nachvollziehen aber hätten sie dann
etwas was sie sich wünschen würden gibt
es ein appell sagen sie okay an dieser
oder jener stelle müsste vielleicht noch
mal an einer schraube gedreht werden
damit sich auch ihre arbeit im
tagtäglichen bessert
also ich würde mir wünschen dass jetzt
und das ist ja auch unser aktueller
anlass das jetzt so konkrete aussagen
die möglich auch aus der
ministerpräsidenten-konferenz
resultieren mir ist klar dass das nicht
in die letzte einzelheiten
ausdifferenziert sein wird dass es dann
noch mal zurück geht auch im
bundesministerium für gesundheit und
dann an die länder kolleginnen und
länder kollegen gefallen herr lauterbach
aber da brauchen wir jetzt möglichst
schnell möglichst konkrete aussagen
damit ihr zu einer spürbaren entlastung
in den laboren am besten in den nächsten
tagen kommen und nicht erst dann wenn
wir möglicherweise schon am
scheitelpunkt der mikrowelle angelangt
sind oder die welle sogar schon abschlag
fabian raddatz war das geschäftsführer
von labor berlin vielen dank für die
zeit die sie sich heute genommen haben
und dankeschön für ihre ausführung
dankeschön gerne so und wir machen
weiter mit nicole diekmann mit meiner
kollegin im hauptstadtstudio heute
allerdings im home-office wie man
erkennen kann nicole du hast eine neue
information für uns es gibt
verlautbarungen seitens eines
regierungssprechers wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe
des regierungssprechers sogar steffen
hebestreit ganz modern schreibt auf
twitter
in kürze die tiere ich gebe es die
pressekonferenz nach der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
im live stream also es scheint sich
jetzt tatsächlich sehr konkrete im ende
da in der großen runde zuzuneigen und
wir bald so erfahren was denn da
beschlossen worden ja das dauert dann
offenbar noch ein paar minütchen und die
zeit müssen wir irgendwie überbrücken
aber in nicole ich bin ja vorsichtig an
meiner seite habe und dann können wir
das ja wunderbar gemeinsam machen ich
gucke gerade ob sich vielleicht noch
eine user frage
irgendwie auf die wir die gemeinsamen
behandeln könnten was ist fragt claudia
hahn über facebook was ist mit den pcr
tests vor einer flugreise ja das weiß
ich jetzt persönlich nicht ob die dann
eventuell jetzt auch davon dann bald
betroffen sind das die da nicht mal so
mir nichts dir nichts gemacht werden
können da bin ich überfragt nicole hast
du deine antwort
ich bin da auch über frag ich finde das
eine super frage und das finde ich
tatsächlich auch ein interessantes thema
denn dann
dann geht es wirklich wild durcheinander
wir erinnern uns an einen flug
vor wenigen wochen der startete in
großbritannien mit komplett negativ
getesteten leuten an bord richtung
indien und als dieses flugzeug infineon
landete wurden 70 leute positiv getestet
also das wäre dann schon sehr mutig noch
nachlegen wenn es vorher keine tests
mehr geht vorbei man aber auch sagen
muss es war ja jetzt bei vielen in
vielen ländern in vielen konstellationen
es ist ja mittlerweile matrix mit der
man arbeiten muss geimpft gewusst hat
nicht geimpft ist es ein risikogebiet
ist aus sicht des landes in das man
fliegt deutschland ein hochrisiko gebiet
ist es ein virus varianten gebiet das
ist ja der alles abgestuft und sehr fein
säuberlich die ganze zeit auch in einer
dynamik drin trotz alledem ist es
wirklich eine spannende frage ob dort wo
bisher pcr tests notwendig waren diese
pcr-test dann wegfallen
ich fürchte allerdings dass
aller voraussicht nach an mit einer
erfahrung die wir mittlerweile ja auch
haben nach diesem pks diese frage gleich
kann rolle spielen wird
vermutlich detail geht man da einfach
nicht ist ja auch die frage ob man ob
man in der runde überhaupt in solche
details gegangen wird vermutlich nicht
aber das ist jetzt spekulation aber ich
hatte den artikel auch gelesen mit der
flugreise nach indien habe ich auch
gedacht also ob ich deswegen jetzt mehr
lust habe mich demnächst in einem
flugzeug zu setzen ich weiß es nicht so
genau und wenn dann die pcr test sondern
auch wegfallen danach geht dann sollte
man vielleicht lieber die finger davon
lassen aber das nur jetzt meine
persönliche einschätzung sprechen wir
noch mal ein bisschen wir gucken gerade
noch mal auf das podium sehen aber dass
da immer noch nichts passiert sprechen
wir vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen
über die bund länder runde wie glaubst
du wie groß war insgesamt dort die
einigkeit in der letzten zeit hatte man
ja doch den eindruck dass die länder und
der bund jetzt auch gerade in der neuen
zusammensetzung mit der neuen
bundesregierung da doch irgendwie sich
relativ schnell immer einig waren jetzt
dauert hat gerade wieder ein bisschen
länger aber wie würdest du so generell
die atmosphäre zwischen bund und ländern
jetzt in der aktuellen situation
beschreiben
na ja ich würde die zweiteilig
beantworten zum einen scheint
tatsächlich olaf scholz sehr darauf
erpicht diesen schlechten ruf den sich
die mpk es in den vergangenen zwei
jahren eingehandelt haben wieder ein
bisschen zu polieren und vorab schon
viel abzuräumen was an konfliktpotenzial
da das sieht man auch an den
unterschiedlichen beschluss verlagen die
sich ja vor so einer entwickler auch
noch mal ändern das ist nicht mehr so
eklatant teilweise wie vorher wo angela
merkel als kanzlerin oft mit mit sehr
weitreichenden und ich nenne das mal
strengen ideen reingegangen ist angela
merkel war sehr sehr vorsichtig im
umgang mit der pandemie konnte sich
dabei auch nicht immer durchsetzen so
das scheint jetzt anders zu sein und
dass es auch auffällig bei der
beschlussvorlage die uns jetzt vorliegt
mit der man heute gearbeitet hat da geht
es zu beginn über eine weite strecke
bezieht sich in der analyse der
situation
das papier diese runde auf die
expertenkommission ja auch mit beginn
der ampel eingesetzt wurde das heißt man
ist eben auch sehr bestrebt darin immer
wieder zu betonen wir müssen unsere
entscheidungen unsere ideen fußen auf
wissenschaftlichen
fundament wir richten uns nach der
wissenschaft soweit das möglich ist dass
ist ja auch immer politik so das heißt
ich glaube dass
man wie gesagt sehr erpicht darauf ist
ein geschlossenes bild nach außen
abzugeben aber ich habe mir eben auch
gesagt ist eine zweigeteilte antwort
interessant ist ja immer schon gewesen
was passiert nach dieser pressekonferenz
zur ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wer
schert aus und es passiert ja immer ist
man eigentlich davon ausgehen dass
erstmal eine erklärung abgegeben wird
wir haben uns geeinigt drauf und dann
sagt ein zwei tage später wenn überhaupt
manchmal auch noch am selben abend tritt
ein ministerpräsident eine
ministerpräsidentin vor die kameras die
natürlich dabei waren ja bei dieser
runde und sagen ja können wir alles gut
aber wir haben uns für einen anderen weg
entschieden infrage xb ziel und das also
kann ja durchaus heute auch wieder so
passieren wir sind gespannt ob das
passieren wird sprechen jetzt dankeschön
nicole für den moment noch mal mit einer
weiteren kapazität kann man sagen
nämlich mit professor hajo c er ist vom
leibniz-institut für präventiv forschung
und epidemiologie einen schönen guten
abend professor z schön dass die zeit
für uns haben hallo hallo
herr professor sid wie bewerten sie denn
die aktuelle maßnahme in situationen die
das bündel was sozusagen auf dem tisch
liegt wir gehen davon aus dass es im
wesentlichen so erhalten bleiben wird
ist das ihrer meinung nach so in ordnung
müsste sich irgendwie gravierend etwas
ändern oder nicht
ja nach allem was ich jetzt bisher
gehört habe ist es ja doch kein so ganz
großartiger wandel der jetzt ansteht wir
leiden wesentlich bei vielen dingen die
bisher auch schon regelbaren ist es eine
frage natürlich die jetzt sich mit den
instanzen verbindet die im moment haben
kann man im moment viel ändern das kann
in die eine richtung gehen dass man sagt
wir müssen doch auch den expertenrat
hören und schon jetzt planen auch noch
verstärkte maßnahmen einzuplanen
aber so wie ich höre bleibt es doch erst
mal bei dem stand der dinge jetzt ist
aber eben auch keine entspannung und
andere länder dadurch auch schon selbst
bei höchsten instanzen dann verkündet in
kürze wird alles gelockert das machen
wir in deutschland offensichtlich auch
nicht finden sie das denn sozusagen
kritikwürdig würden sie es gerne anders
haben anders sehen
jetzt nicht über das lockere ausführlich
reden das passt mir schon ganz gut denn
tatsächlich sind im moment noch in einer
kritischen situation ganz klar und ich
bin sicher dass mehr kolleginnen
kollegen die jetzt in krankenhäusern
arbeiten da zustimmen würden das ist
noch alles nicht so dass man jetzt
wirklich viel sagen könnte dazu wie
alles
günstiger aussehen wird in ihrer zeit
erstmal was wir jetzt hier rüber kommen
und da ist es glaube ich schon auch ganz
fair gerade denen gegenüber zu sagen nee
jetzt konzentrieren uns darauf dass wir
durch diese durch diese welle kommen ihr
schaltet er war ich man dann sprechen
wir im detail darüber was verändert
werden kann ja dann reden wir über die
aktuelle situation noch ein bisschen
weiter die hatten es würden ja auch
schon erwähnt es geht um unter anderem
auch bei diesen ganzen maßnahmen um die
knappheit an pcr tests waren sie als sie
davon erfahren haben überrascht dass
diese situation so eingetreten ist denn
wie gesagt so eine gewisse art barkeit
dass es da also einen bedarf geben wird
auch vielleicht einen hohen bedarf die
war ja schon da
also deutschland hat sich eigentlich
immer durchaus auch zu recht gerügt dass
wir den früheren testen begonnen haben
und auch relativ große kapazitäten
hatten das hat sich jetzt natürlich mit
mikro noch mal richtig geändert weil
hier jetzt
fallzahlen
von infektionen da sind die wir so nicht
gekannt habe und selbst unsere 2,4
millionen ca tests pcs pro woche reichen
jetzt tatsächlich für all das was man
damit testen müsste und insofern ist es
einerseits überraschend dass wir da
jetzt landen aber es ist fast mehr der
seite des virus als der seite der
kapazität quasi geschuldet so würde ich
das einschätzen die kapazität ist recht
groß sie könnte sich ja noch größer sein
aber man muss natürlich auch überlegen
könnte man da so steuern dass man immer
sehr sehr große kapazitäten vorhält die
man gar nicht braucht auch das muss
natürlich überlegt sein es ist jetzt
also wirklich ein kluges und und
schlaues vorgehen nötig um jetzt an den
stellen wo wirklich auch bei pc ja nicht
unbedingt gebraucht werden diese dann
nicht zu nutzen und die zu konzentrieren
das ist schon gut allerdings auf kosten
der tatsache dass wir bei wenigsten
überblick verlieren was wir genau an
infektionen haben ja das ist natürlich
weniger gut das stimmt aber reden wir
gerade vielleicht noch mal über omikron
mit ja welchen augen blicken sie jetzt
auf diese variante die ja nun doch eben
die vorherrschende inzwischen ist und
die sich rasant ausbreitet was gibt es
zu nikon aus fachlicher sicht zu sagen
stand heute
ja also umgekommen ist auch dächer
gefolgt mit erstmal auf der günstigen
seite an weniger schweren
krankheitsverlauf weniger großer
häufigkeit von schweren verläufen das
ist ja nun schon bekannt und das ist
auch mittlerweile ganz gut in studien
gezeigt worden dass dem wirklich so ist
es müssen also wirklich weniger menschen
mit omikron auf intensivstationen
überhaupt in krankenhäusern behandelt
werden aber es gibt auf der anderen
seite eben dieses phänomen dass des
immun escapes das heißt die variante in
zieht sich der in aufgebauten immunität
zu einem gewissen grade die immunität
die in viele von uns jetzt über die
impfung bekommen haben oder aber auch
durch eine erkrankung vorher die
allerdings nicht so umfangreich ist dann
immunität das macht uni kann auch sehr
effizient und damit kommt es halt zu
diesem doch ja gigantischen den
fallzahlen die jetzt ja auch noch weiter
ansteigen
wir haben wie gesagt eine ganz guten
schutz durch impfungen vor allem durch
das boostern das sind alles dinge die
jetzt auf der positiven seite sind aber
wir werden im moment eben noch mit stark
ansteigenden zahlen vor allen dingen
dort wo viele menschen zusammenkommen
dass die häufig jetzt eben steht da geht
es besonders rasant hoch zu tun haben
und dass dort noch moment ist sie da den
scheitel erreicht haben werden jetzt
gibt es ja die leute die sagen ach gut
dass es ohne grund gibt der verlauf
scheint eher milde zu sein und wenn dann
möglichst viele damit in kontakt kommen
dann wird sich sozusagen das immer mehr
dann der in de mission situationen dann
annähern aber dann gibt es die anderen
die sagen na ja also auf die leichte
schulter zu nehmen ist es dann trotzdem
nicht dann wenn sich so viele infizieren
gibt es darunter daneben auch schwere
verläufe wenn auch vielleicht prozentual
nicht ganz so viele wie würden sie die
gefahren situation einschätzen
jetzt ist es tatsächlich die schiere
menge an fällen wir haben tatsächlich
anteilig weniger schwere verläufe aber
die gesamtzahl so groß ist dann bleibt
jedoch meine ganze menge von menschen
die einfach dann ins krankenhaus müssen
nun auch noch behandelt werden müssen
das ist schon so dass es einfach die
sachen incidence
geschuldet es ist sicher auch richtig
dass ich eine immunität aufhebt der
jetzt für nikon zusammen mit den
impfungen dann quasi in die balance
geführt oder in einer art von von
erhöhter immunität in der
gesamtbevölkerung ja das ist auch
richtig dabei ist die immunität durch
die impfung immer der durch erkrankung
vorzuziehen denn natürlich führte sonst
kann der erkrankung zu longo mitführen
und auch die immunität scheint nicht so
ausgeprägt zu sein wie durch die
erkrankung es ist aber noch nicht das
letzte wort gesprochen ob er wirklich in
dem ische situation kommen denn leider
muss man halt
erkennen und wissen da wäre es variiert
baut neue mutanten haben wir schon
mehrfach erlebt und wir haben dann
glücklicherweise eben situationen wo wir
diese gute und immunität brauchen oder
auch noch mal was drauf setzen müssen
wird weiter das ist jetzt die situation
und da ist es ja wir müssen da sehr
genau schauen und da viele informationen
sammelt weiterhin um zu wissen was auch
in den nächsten monaten auch in zukunft
ja das wissen wir natürlich jetzt alles
noch nicht in der tat das bleibt auch
eine ganz spannende frage was kommt da
noch eventuell welche anderen mutationen
kommen dann auch noch dazu lk lka fragt
uns über youtube eine zugegebenermaßen
eher weniger akademische eher eine
pragmatische frage kann man die kosten
für den pcr test hinterher bei der
krankenkasse einreichen für eine
erstattung ich selber weiß es nicht ich
glaube wenn der schnelltest positiv ist
oder helfen sie mir wissen sie da
antwort solange es also bisher ist noch
so lange 1 1 pcr-test quasi angeordnet
ist und in die
in die regeln fällt dann das wirst du
schon gestattet ja das ist noch so genau
aber das ist eben wie gesagt jetzt die
frage wer in zukunft überhaupt die pcr
tests machen soll wir hatten es
besprochen es herrscht eine gewisse
knappheit und es ist eben gerade
gegenstand auf der diskussion wie in
zukunft mit dem pad pcr tests weiter
umgegangen werden soll kommt vielleicht
noch zu einem anderen thema kontakt
beschränkungen was ist da aus ihrer
sicht herr professor zeeb sinnvoll wie
sollten da die quarantäne regeln zum
beispiel in zukunft aussehen das ist ja
auch viel diskutiert worden wie lange
sollten sich die menschen ab sondern
wann sollten sie die möglichkeit haben
wieder zurück zu kommen sind sie da mit
dem aktuellen status quo zufrieden oder
meinen sie es müsste strenger seien
weniger streng wie ist ihre einschätzung
aus meiner sicht ist das hauptproblem
moment tatsächlich die regelung dass man
als gemusterte person quasi gar nicht
mehr als kontakt gilt das glaube ich ist
nicht so vorsichtig wie es sein sollte
denn tatsächlich haben auch jetzt leider
schon eben viele gemusterte dann
tatsächlich auch eine virusinfektion und
müssen
insofern dann auch können dann auch die
infektion natürlich weitergeben und und
das ist glaube ich jetzt eine situation
die nicht optimal gelöst wird wir sind
insgesamt natürlich auf der schiene dass
wir garantieren verkürzen ich weiß das
für sinnvoll dass mit dem test auch
wirklich dann abzuschließen und das eher
weichen meiner meinung nach tatsächlich
dann in den meisten fällen antigen test
vielleicht auch zwei wiederholte an die
gentests
dass das ist alles glaube ich auf dem
richtigen weg man muss es jetzt sehr
genau prüfen wie das in schulen und den
kitas weiter geht glaube ich weil da
halt jetzt zunehmend einfach quasi in
den doktor und durch die hintertür kommt
durch qualitäten die einfach wiederholt
werden weil immer wieder ganze gruppen
in quarantäne geschickt werden das jetzt
eine problematik da müssen noch etwas
intelligente lösungen gefunden werden
wobei testen immer eine große rolle
spielen wird bei allen um eben zu wissen
was kann man sich leisten und was kann
man nicht schwimmen ja also das impfen
ist wichtig ist einmal festgehalten dass
testen aber hat auch seine wichtigkeit
und seine berechtigung vielleicht zum
schluss auch noch mal erzählt der blick
irgendwie sozusagen in die glaskugel mit
welcher entwicklung rechnen sie also in
den nächsten wochen und monaten herr
lauterbach macht ja dann doch immer mal
wieder auch leise hoffnungen dass es
dann sozusagen mit mitte ende februar
wieder besser werden könnte dann kommt
die wärmere jahreszeit und sodann hat
man den eindruck okay das leben
entwickelt sich wieder etwas positiver
wie ist ihre einschätzung 9 also da
würde ich auch sicherlich zustimmen nach
allem was ich sehe was ich was wir aus
den letzten jahren auch weiß der der
frühling und sommer werden die zahlen
sicher runter gehen und wir es gibt ja
auch doch schon eine ganze menge
modellen sich das genauer angucken und
eigentlich gegen die alle davon aus dass
man auf einem niedrigen niveau nach
diesen scheitel der welle dann kommt das
wann genau das ist das ist sicherlich
ein bisschen abhängig davon was man
einnimmt in den in den schätzungen den
modellen aber es wird sich jetzt um den
februar wesentlichen handeln ende
februar vielleicht dass es dann deutlich
runter geht und dass wir dann zum sommer
hin tatsächlich mit niedrigen fallzahlen
zu tun haben und das ist dann auch genau
die zeit die man nutzen muss um sich für
den kommenden winter gut zu rüsten das
sollte nicht wieder so werden wie dieses
jahr wo wir eine gewisse spannung hatten
von zwei nicht viel passierte wir haben
möglichkeiten wir können wahrscheinlich
auch mit spezifischen am nikon impfungen
arbeiten in zukunft
das wird ganz gut sein aber ich glaube
insgesamt kann man auch eine gewisse
entspannung auf jeden fall offen und ja
eine schlaue entspannung ist nötig also
sich nicht zu sehr entspannend und
zusagen auch alles ist vorbei so schnell
geht es dann doch nicht aber es wird
schon vorbei gehen ja das ist wäre schon
mal ein ganz persönliches schlusswort
aber ich würde gern noch eine frage doch
dann draufsetzen weil das eben auch ein
thema ist was von professor aber auch
oft angesprochen wird ist eben noch mal
die gefahr neuer varianten und zum
mutationen für wie wahrscheinlich halten
sie dass das dann eventuell entweder
eine kombination aus delta und unbekannt
oder noch mal was ganz neues auf uns
zukommt dann spätestens im herbst
ja jetzt geht es wirklich um
meinungen mehr denn wissen aber man muss
einfach aus der aus der bisherigen
geschichte der der pandemie sehen dass
solche entwicklungen im jahr an der
tagesordnung sind die virusvariante
und mutiert permanent hat jetzt auch
natürlich sehr viele
wirte sehr viele menschen in denen das
ganze stattfindet und sich möglichkeiten
ergeben und ist es auch darauf
hingewiesen worden dass sehr ungünstig
ist wenn die immunität quasi
unterschiedlich an unterschiedlichen
stellen sich unterschiedlich schnell
entwickelt und das haben wir leider in
deutschland eben auch weil der region
haben mit hohen quote und und andere mit
niedrigerer impfquote und weltweit dies
genau so aus das ist schon das problem
dass eben eine gewisse
wahrscheinlichkeit mit sich bringt dass
solche entwicklung wie eine neue
variante oder auch mehreren relevanten
varianten dann auftreten können
man kann es wirklich überhaupt nicht
ausschließen und sollte deswegen aber
jetzt nicht in
zweifel und unmut und trauer verfallen
sondern sagen ja wir das beste was wir
machen können ist im moment unser
immunität aufbauen durch durch impfungen
und gleichzeitig eben wissen dass da
noch was kommen kann und dass wir dann
aber auch möglichkeiten haben wir haben
effektive passt wir haben die ganze
menge gelernt dass das umgehen angegeben
mit solchen situationen und ich glaube
darauf muss man jetzt fusion hoffnung
sich nicht zu sehr verwirren lassen
davon dass es natürlich auch noch mal
wieder entwicklung geben kann wie man
sich nicht so erhofft ja ein schönes
schlusswort professor hc war das vom
leibniz-institut für präventiv forschung
und epidemiologie wir versuchen uns
unseren optimismus zu bewahren und mit
diesen dann in die nächsten wochen und
monaten zu gehen auch wenn es noch
vielleicht ein bisschen haarig werden
könnte danke schön für das gespräch und
einen schönen abend danke sehr ich danke
auch so und dann kommen wir noch mal
zurück nach berlin gucken vielleicht
gerade noch mal auf die pressekonferenz
sehen aber dass ich da immer noch nicht
also es dauert noch aber kein problem
denn nicole diekmann ist nach wie vor
für uns nicht vor ort und stelle aber
sie ist für unser ansprechbar nicole
also es wird offenbar immer noch
gerungen könntest du dir vorstellen
worüber noch gestritten wird woran
vielleicht noch gefeilt werden könnte
es ist tatsächlich eine gute frage ich
hab ja heute schon zu beginn gesagt dass
ich spannend finde
obwohl der schwerpunkt gelegt wird
bei der eröffnungs perspektive dass das
co2 in der beschlussvorlage
der man sich heute entlanghangelt oder
ob im vordergrund steht die fortsetzung
der bestehenden maßnahmen bisher gehen
wir alle davon aus dass eine
verschärfung der bisher bestehenden
maßnahmen erst mal ausgeschlossen ist
bis zum nächsten treffen das mitte
februar übrigens stattfinden soll wenn
vorher nichts bahnbrechendes passiert
also wir haben da
leute sitzen unter anderem hendrik wüst
der in den vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
den
ministerpräsidenten von nrw der hut war
und die möchte er gerne gewinnen
und er gehört zu denjenigen wieder
verwarnen jetzt 52 eröffnungs
perspektiven zu sehr in den fokus zu
rücken der setzt also darauf bei den
wählerinnen und wählern mit vorsicht zu
punkten es kann sein dass der jetzt
gerade versucht sich
durchzusetzen mit mit seiner nähen hier
wer weiß ob er der widerstand touch von
anderen ministerpräsidenten mit würde
das spontan zum beispiel markus söder
einfallen
ministerpräsident von bayern dessen
umfragewerte in den keller abgerutscht
sind das muss man so sagen
und der sich interessanterweise
vielleicht zufällig vielleicht nicht
auch jetzt gerade er vom team vorsicht
verabschiedet das heißt wie ich das mag
musst du da jetzt gleichzeitig wird aber
er spricht von augenmaß und klingt damit
schon etwas anders also augen das heißt
man müsse auch die regelungen und die
vorsicht anpassen an die neuen
gegebenheiten spricht romy cron ist zwar
hoch infektiös viel ansteckender als es
delta war aber so wie es aussieht ist es
nicht so gefährlich wie data bringt
nicht so viele menschen auch die
intensivstation und damit also das
gesundheitssystem an den rande des
kollaps das wäre möglich dass da sich
die diskussion heute sehr lange drum
gedreht hat andrea brem schreibt uns
über facebook ich dachte die beschließen
nichts neues was dauert denn dann ja die
frage ist berechtigt und wir wie gesagt
wissen es auch nicht darüber rätseln wir
auch schon seit geraumer zeit aber wir
können nur versprechen dass wir drauf
gehen sobald es losgeht
nicole du hast gerade den
ministerpräsidenten von nrw herrn wüst
angesprochen da finden wahlen statt in
der tat aber auch in schleswig holstein
und auch im saarland finden wahlen statt
könnten auch diese
herren sind es ja
geneigt sein eventuell auch diese bühne
noch einmal zu nutzen um auf sich
aufmerksam zu machen wie schätzt du das
also ich würde mal sagen dass alle die
da heute sitzen gerne ihren job
weitermachen möchten beziehungsweise
auch ihrer partei den dienst erweisen
möchten an der an der macht zu bleiben
und so eine ministerpräsidenten konnte
es ist natürlich in diesen zeiten von
corona was ganz außergewöhnliches denn
das ist ja diese besonderheit für uns
alle in der pandemie was da beschlossen
wird greift 1 zu 1 unmittelbar in unser
leben rasches design unser aller alltag
nehmen kann sich dem entziehen ja es
geht los es geht los ich danke dir für
diese ausführung genau und wir sprechen
gleich weiter hören aber jetzt natürlich
den bundeskanzler und melden uns gleich
zurück
meine damen meine herren ich darf sie
herzlich begrüßen zur pressekonferenz im
anschluss an die zusammenkunft des
bundeskanzlers mit den
regierungschefinnen und regierungschefs
der länder ich darf hier neben den
bundeskanzler olaf scholz begrüßen die
regierende bürgermeisterin von berlin
franziska giffey und den nordrhein
westfälischen ministerpräsidenten
hendrik wüst und wie üblich beginnt der
bundeskanzler
meine damen und herren bevor ich zu den
ergebnissen der zusammenkunft der
regierungschef im regierungschefs der
länder mit dem bundeskanzler komme
möchte ich ganz kurz machnig bestürzen
zum ausdruck bringen über einen vorfall
den es am nachmittag in heidelberg
gegeben hat dort hatte ein amokläufer an
der universität das feuer auf
studierende eröffnet und mehrere
menschen verletzt
eine studentin ist so wird berichtet
dann zwischen ihren schweren
verletzungen erlegen der täter soll sich
danach selbst erschossen haben es
zerreißt mir das herz solch eine
nachricht zu erfahren mein beileid ist
bei den angehörigen und den opfern und
natürlich bei den studentinnen und
studenten der universität heidelberg
und herren wir sind heute erneut
zusammengekommen um über die roma
pandemie und das gemeinsame management
dieser pandemie untereinander zu beraten
für uns alle ist klar dass die
richtung die wir eingeschlagen haben
hilft dass sie dazu beigetragen habe
dass wir die korona pandemie in
deutschland in der gegenwärtigen
situation anders bewältigen können als
viele unserer nachbarländer und das ist
deshalb wichtig ist diesen kurs
fortzusetzen
dazu gehört zuallererst dass wir in
deutschland sehr strenge kontakt
beschränkungen haben die notwendig sind
für die zusammenkünfte im privaten
bereich für den zugang zu geschäften zu
restaurants zur veranstaltung zu gehen
was
dazu führt dass viele menschen
miteinander zusammen kommen und deshalb
natürlich auch die ansteckungsgefahr
damit erhöht sagt diese regelung haben
dazu beigetragen dass bei uns die hohen
infektionszahlen die uns noch ende
letzten jahres vorhergesagt worden sind
erst jetzt erreicht worden sind viel
später als in vielen nachbarländern
trotzdem sind es sehr hohe
infektionszahlen und deshalb gilt für
uns auch dass wir unverändert vorsichtig
bleiben müssen und diesen kurs auch
beibehalten werden darauf haben sich
bund und länder in dieser zusammenkunft
miteinander verständigt wir wissen noch
nicht wie sich die infektionen weiter
entwickeln werden ob wir mit einer
dramatischen situation noch rechnen
müssen im zusammenhang mit den
steigenden infektionszahlen durch die
hoch ansteckende omikron variante oder
ob wir bald schon sehen können dass wir
ganz gut durch diese zeit kommen in
beiden fällen und in beide richtungen
werden wir dann zur richtigen zeit die
notwendigen entscheidungen treffen jetzt
aber gilt erstmal kurs halten
das zweite was wir in dieser situation
mit großer anstrengung auf den weg
gebracht haben ist eine neue kampagne zu
kämpfen und postern in deutschland wir
hatten uns vor weihnachten vorgenommen
bis weihnachten 30 millionen impfungen
zu erreichen dass es auch gelungen wir
fahren unverändert fort möglichst viele
davon zu überzeugen dass sie sich eine
auffrischungsimpfung holen das tempo hat
nachgelassen das ist etwas was wir
konstatieren müssen trotzdem geht es
voran sowohl mit den erste impfung als
auch mit den auffrischungsimpfungen wo
wir schon eine hohe zahl von bürgerinnen
und bürgern erreicht haben und das soll
jetzt in den nächsten tagen und wochen
weitergehen dass aber die
bundesregierung auch im übrigen sich
entschlossen ihre werbliche kampagne in
diesem zusammenhang noch einmal neu
aufzulegen sie sehen hinter mir hilft
das ist nur ein ganz kleiner auszug von
dem was wir uns vorgenommen haben das
kommt noch viele viele andere dazu vom
radio spot zur benutzung der
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten
die sich mit social media verbinden und
alles dazu beitragen dass die zahl
derjenigen die sich jetzt entschließen
sich das erste mal impfen zu lassen und
die zahl derjenigen die sich jetzt eine
auffrischungsimpfung polen noch mal
erheblich zunimmt wir versuchen auch in
viele zielgruppen hineinzukommen
bürgerinnen und bürger zu erreichen die
bisher von den verschiedenen
informations aktivitäten nicht erreicht
worden denn es gilt wie oben drauf steht
impfen hilft selbst die erste impfung
schützt vor schwierigen
verläufen wer als wenn man nicht geimpft
ist und das gilt natürlich insbesondere
für all diejenigen die eine musterung
haben deutschland ist dass die im zahlen
betrifft sehr weit gekommen aber nicht
hoch genug wir haben jetzt knapp 75
prozent der bevölkerung erst genf das
muss viel mehr sein und da sind wir auch
schlechter als das verzeichnet werden
kann als in anderen ländern aber wir
sind sehr gut was das boostern betrifft
und deshalb wollen wir beides beitrag
voranbringen die auffrischungsimpfung
die erstimpfung
dementsprechend gehört zu unseren
beschlüssen die heute gefasst haben die
fortgeltung der bisherigen maßnahmen mit
dem was ich gesagt habe wir haben uns
auch unterhalten über die überregionalen
großveranstaltungen wie das weiter
organisiert werden soll und über das
impfen auch darüber gibt es große
einigkeit dass wir die bürgerinnen
bürger mit dem ausreichend zur verfügung
bestehenden impfstoff weiter versorgen
wollen und dass wir alle bitten von der
möglichkeit gebrauch zu machen
es muss und wird getestet werden
angesichts der jetzt schon hohen und
absehbaren noch höheren infektionszahlen
wegen der ansteckenden omikron variante
gilt es jetzt aber eine richtige nutzung
der testmöglichkeiten zu organisieren
dazu haben wir die gesundheitsministerin
gesundheitsminister der länder zusammen
mit dem bundesminister gesundheit
gebeten eine bis ins letzte detail
ausbalancierte strategie vorzulegen die
es möglich macht dass wir einen guten
überblick behalten über das
infektionsgeschehen dass wir aber
gleichzeitig all die möglichkeiten die
haben mit pcr test und antigen tests
nutzen um auch möglichst viele
unterstützen zu können
wir haben uns unterhalten der kantine
und isolation die regelung sind
verändert worden und werden auch weiter
verändert werden bei uns geht es darum
dass wir hier pragmatisch sind auch da
werden wir uns in den werden wir uns
weiter mit den fragen beschäftigen wie
das organisiert werden soll sie kennen
die entscheidung der letzten tage und
der zeit wir haben uns auch mit dem
genesenen und im status beschäftigt da
hat es noch mal eine diskussion gegeben
weil die veränderte rechts und
gesetzeslage dazu geführt hat dass jetzt
entscheidung sehr schnell getroffen
werden können das ist ja einerseits gut
andererseits führt es dazu dass man die
entscheidung dann im auch für den einen
oder anderen sehr überraschend kommen
und wir haben uns darauf verständigt
dass wir jetzt das so organisieren
wollen das mit den notwendigen
vorkehrungen immer klar ist dass man
sich rechtzeitig einstellen kann auf die
veränderung die bevorstehen es sei denn
eine ganz dramatische entwicklung in der
pandemie lässt uns keine wahl aber das
ist ja keine wahrscheinlichkeit sondern
deshalb soll das so sein
wir sind uns darüber einig dass wir
alles dafür tun müssen die männer und
frauen denn den alten einrichtungen zu
den pflegeeinrichtungen zu schützen wir
arbeiten weiter daran unsere kritische
infrastruktur stabil zu halten in dieser
zeit und wir haben uns fest vorgenommen
dass wir die digitalisierung des
gesundheitswesens
weiter vorantreiben wollen der expert
das expertengremium das wir eingerichtet
haben hat uns hier weitreichende
vorschläge gemacht die jetzt intensiv
beraten werden es gibt einen großen
konsens darüber dass wir diese
digitalisierung als eine der lehren aus
der korona pandemie und den dingen die
wir besser machen müssen vorantreiben
werden und ich sehe dort eine gemeinsame
anstrengung vor uns zu der alle bereit
sind dann haben wir noch mal gesagt dass
es weitergehen soll mit
wirtschaftshilfen und kurzarbeitergeld
die uns so weit durch die krise geführt
haben die bundesregierung wird jetzt
ganz zeitnah prüfen was noch
weiterentwickelt was weitergeführt
werden muss so dass wir auch noch den
letzten zeit punkte der krise gut
bewältigen können insgesamt also eine
sehr gute und mit die letzten male auch
nicht allzu lange sich hinziehende
konferenz ein gutes gespräch zwischen
den regierungschefin regierungschefs der
länder untereinander und mit dem
bundeskanzler und der regierung und ich
glaube das wäre auch gut durch die krise
kommen werden wenn das genauso
weitermachen ich bedanke mich sehr bei
dem krisenstab der uns hilft general
breuer war erneut dabei und hat unsere
beratung unterstützt ich berate danke
mich ausdrücklich bei dem experten geben
wir ein professor krömer hat uns die
dortigen beratung geschildert und uns
damit auch einen wichtigen hinweis für
unsere eigenen entscheidungen gegeben
insgesamt gilt also kurs halten was das
vorsichtig bleiben in dem begriff
kontakte betrifft kurs halten auch was
impfen und postern betrifft dann haben
wir eine gute chance durch diese
schwierige gesundheitskrise weiter gut
durchzukommen
vielen dank als nächstes ist der
vorsitzende der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz erwischt
vielen herzlichen dank fast genau vor
zwei jahren ins corona nach deutschland
gekommen seitdem hat die pandemie
menschenleben gekostet und viele
menschen sehr belastet unser land
befindet sich seit fast zwei jahren
einen ständigen spirale aus lockt downs
und
lockerungen und der weg raus aus dieser
spirale führt nur über achtsamkeit
voraussicht und impfungen die pandemie
ist derzeit hoch dynamisch
bundesgesundheitsminister hat vor
einigen tagen ein best case szenario
beschrieben nachdem mitte februar ein
peak erreicht werden könnte mit 400.000
infizierten neuinfizierten am tag dazu
kommt jetzt zum zweiten mal in folge zum
zweiten tag in folge
eine höhere belegung der
intensivstationen die experten der
expertenrat der bundesregierung hält
auch eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems bei nikon für möglich
der expertenrat hat diese in dieser lage
eine klare mahnung ausgesprochen das
infektionsgeschehen erfordert die
beibehaltung und strikte umsetzung der
bisherigen maßnahmen
motto länder sind sich deshalb einig
dass die bisher geltenden regeln
grundsätzlich weiterhin bestand haben
wir müssen in den nächsten wochen aber
in beide richtungen blicken wenn eine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems oder
der kritischen infrastruktur droht
müssen weitergehende maßnahmen
vereinbart werden andersherum gilt aber
auch bund und länder werden öffnungs
perspektiven entwickeln für den moment
zudem eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystem ausgeschlossen werden
kann
impfungen bleiben der beste weg um unser
gesundheitssystem zu schützen das impfen
ist der weg raus aus der pandemie impfen
und achtsamkeit sind der weg zurück zur
normalität für alle die seit zwei jahren
sehr unter dieser pandemie leiden erster
stelle natürlich all die menschen die
auf den intensivstationen
arbeiten die belastet sind überlastet
sind ja und einigen teilen auch wirklich
ausgelaugt und frustriert pflegerinnen
und pfleger ärztinnen und ärzte auch die
eltern die sich sorgen machen ob sie
ihre kinder mit einem guten gefühl in
die kita in die schule schicken können
auch die menschen im handel in der
gastronomie in der
veranstaltungswirtschaft und anderen
branche die sehr eingeschränkt sind wir
kommen nur heraus aus den ständigen
wiederholungen von law und lockerungen
wenn
menschen geimpft sind wir haben in
deutschland aktuell eine impfquote von
75 prozent das ist schlicht noch zu
wenig der expertenrat hält deshalb für
erforderlich verbliebene im flecken zu
schließen bund und länder haben deshalb
heute bekräftigt dass sie die
vorbereitung einer allgemeinen
impfpflicht für notwendig halten eine
impfpflicht schützt vor allem besonders
gefährdete menschen und auch diejenigen
die sich nicht impfen lassen können eine
impfpflicht gehört deshalb zu einer
vorausschauenden pandemie politik dazu
für die unionsgeführten bundesländer
habe ich schon in der vergangenen woche
gespräche über die vorbereitung einer
impfpflicht angeboten denn die länder
werden ja vermutlich bei der umsetzung
eine wichtige rolle spielen müssen in
dem bundeskanzler sehr dankbar dass er
dieses angebot heute auch angenommen hat
und er dafür sorgen möchte dass diese
gespräche zwischen bundesregierung in
fraktionen im bundestag und den ländern
stattfinden können wir sind zu einer
konstruktiven zusammenarbeit gerne
bereit denn unser land ist immer dann am
stärksten wenn wir über alle staatlichen
ebenen hinweg bund länder und auch die
kommunen sollen dabei nicht vergessen
werden eng zusammenarbeiten
ein breiter konsens im bundestag
und bundesrat zu diesem thema
impfpflicht kann auch die akzeptanz in
dieser wichtigen maßnahme deutlich
erhöhen wer heute auch über die test
strategie gesprochen die hohe zahl von
neuinfektionen führt zu engpässen bei
der verfügbarkeit von pcr test der
gesundheitsminister die
gesundheitsminister haben deshalb eine
priorisierung beschlossen aus unserer
sicht muss gleichzeitig aber auch daran
gearbeitet werden die pcr test kapazität
schnellstmöglich zu erhöhen das erwarten
die bürgerinnen und bürger zu recht
insbesondere mit blick auf nachbarländer
die da deutlich größere kapazitäten
vorhalten zu helfen jetzt keine
schuldzuweisungen in die eine wie die
andere richtig richtung wichtig ist dass
wir in der lage arbeiten dass das besser
wird und deshalb ist gut dass der
gesundheitsminister zugesagt hat auch an
der ausleitung der test kapazitäten zu
arbeiten da wollte auch über die
festlegung zum genesenen status und zum
impfstatus gesprochen bund und länder
haben in der vorvergangenen woche
gemeinsam beschlossen dass das robert
koch institut und das
paul-ehrlich-institut den impfstatus und
den genesenen status näher bestimmen
dürfen bundesrat das am 14 januar
beschlossen hat dem zugestimmt einen tag
später hat das lka die dauer des
genesenen status dann kurzfristig und
unangekündigt von 180 tage auf 90 tage
verkürzt das hat viele menschen
überrascht und verunsichert alle länder
und zwar parteiübergreifend
fahren sich heute einig dass sich das
nicht wiederholen darf es war wichtig
dass der bundesgesundheitsminister
heute zugesagt hat entsprechende
vorkehrungen für die zukunft zu treffen
solche änderungen brauchen einen
angemessenen vorlauf die menschen müssen
sich darauf auch ein stück vorbereiten
können zu einer vorausschauenden
pandemie politik gehört eben auch
verlässlichkeit
nicola die pandemie verändert die
mutation erfordert von uns allen größte
wachsamkeit wir müssen in den nächsten
wochen die entwicklung aller parameter
ganz genau beobachten und bei bedarf
schnell reagieren bund und länder werden
sich in diesem format spätestens am 16
februar wieder treffen aber wenn es
vorher entscheidungsbedarf gibt bin ich
sicher dass wir auch in der lage sind
früher zusammen zu kommen vielen dank
dann als dritter berlins regierende
bürgermeisterin von ist das kalkül sein
ja meine damen und herren sehr geehrter
herr bundeskanzler sehr geehrter herr
kollege wüst unser
letztendlich motto für heute es geht um
wieder lockern noch verschärfen sondern
schulter dass er schon gesagt und groß
halten es geht darum dass wir uns einig
waren dass eine lockerung der maßnahmen
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt mit den
entsprechen
infektionszahlen nicht das mittel der
wahl ist das aber auch in anhand der
empfehlungen des expertenrates eine
weitere verschärfung nicht angezeigt ist
und mir ist wichtig dabei dass die
diskussion der letzten tage die wir auch
aus berlin und von seiten verschiedener
länder eingebracht haben um letztendlich
den dreiklang aus dem schutz der
kritischen infrastruktur der
überarbeitung der kontakt nach
verfolgung der stärkeren fokus iq
fokussierung der kontakt nach verfolgung
und der veränderung des test regimes
heute eingang in diese beschlussfassung
gefunden ich finde es gut dass wir uns
verständigen konnten es gerade bei der
kritischen infrastruktur wir in allen
ländern und dem bund gemeinsam eben mit
den betreibern der kritischen
infrastrukturen ein kontinuierliches
monitoring nicht nur einführen sondern
auch eben entsprechend bedarfsgerecht
weiterentwickeln
wir haben schon jetzt in vielen
bereichen der kritischen infrastruktur
ja eine sehr genaue planung und
vorbereitung auf die pandemie folgen
auch die vorbereitung auf einen starken
personalausfall dass es heute noch
einmal bekräftigt worden dass eben dort
auch die pläne angepasst werden müssen
und getroffene maßnahmen eben auch dazu
beitragen die grundversorgung der
bevölkerung aufrecht zu erhalten das ist
bisher gelungen und das ist auch unser
ganz großes ziel dass der schutz der
kritischen infrastruktur und das
entsprechende monitoring- in all den
bereichen von der strom wasserversorgung
über ernährung und auch was die
rettungsdienste feuerwehr polizei und so
weiter angeht dass das aufrechterhalten
genauso wie die gesundheitliche
versorgung deswegen ist gut dass sich
heute eben auch nochmal auf den fokus
monitoring- geeinigt worden ist zum
zweiten das thema test regime es ist
ganz klar dass mit den erhöhten zahlen
wir eben nicht mehr einfach genauso
weiter testen wie wir das bisher getan
haben dass es eine fokussierung braucht
eine schwerpunktsetzung bei den pcr
tests auf diejenigen die mit den ganz
besonders vor wahlen gruppen arbeiten
das betrifft die krankenhäuser das
betrifft die pflegeeinrichtung aber auch
die
eingliederungshilfe und die
einrichtungen der eingliederungshilfe
und hier geht es eben darum dass die pcs
vor allen dingen dort verwendet werden
wo diese gruppen mit anderen
wohlhabenden personen arbeiten und das
ansonsten eben ein test regime
erarbeiten das tatsächlich auch die den
einsatz und die anerkennung der antiken
schnittes entsprechend
verwirklicht und zwar wichtig dass wir
das eben heute nicht einfach in der mpk
abschließend besprechen sondern dass der
bundesminister für gesundheit in
abstimmung mit den gesundheitsministerin
und ministern der länder hier ein
verändertes test regime ausarbeiten wird
und das ist eine nationale test
strategie mit der entsprechenden
anpassung der korona virus test
verordnung anhand der neuen
gegebenheiten gibt und gleichzeitig herr
kollege wüst hat dass er schon gesagt
eben alle bemühungen alle anstrengungen
unternommen werden um die pcr test
kapazitäten zu erhöhen und auszuweiten
und der dritte bereich das thema kontakt
nachverfolgung auch hier ist ganz klar
dass wir bei den zahlen unter denen wir
im moment sind doch gerade in den großen
städten in den sättigt beliebte
siedelten lagen wir eine kontakt nach
verfolgung durch die gesundheitsämter so
wie wir sie bisher kannten nicht
fortführen können werden sondern dass es
um eine fokussierte kontakt
nachverfolgung gehen muss auch
entsprechend der quarantäne regeln die
wir schon getroffen haben und auch hier
ist verständigt worden dass die
regierungschefin regierungschefs der
länder die konferenz der
gesundheitsministerin und
gesundheitsminister eben bitten hier
zeitnah in zusammenarbeit mit dem robert
koch-institut umsetzbare neue regelung
zu erarbeiten damit entsprechend auch
die kontakt nachverfolgung darauf
konzentriert werden kann
erstens was leistbar und zweitens
natürlich auch auf die wohngruppen zielt
wir haben uns darüber hinaus dazu
verständigt dass es sehr wichtig ist
dass auch die an die eigenverantwortung
der bürgerinnen und bürger noch einmal
appelliert wird nicht nur was das impfen
angeht sondern auch weil es die
eigenverantwortliche
kommunikation mit kontaktpersonen angeht
was die verwendung elektronischer
hilfsmittel zur kontakt nach vollziehung
angeht ich glaube das ist sehr wichtig
dass wir alle jeder einzelne von uns
sein und ihren beitrag leistet sollte
man selbst an sich symptom oder ein
positiv test
vorliegen haben das dann eben auch
persönlich in eigenverantwortung die
notwendigen schritte ergriffen werden
ich will noch einmal verstärken zum
thema impfen wir können sagen dass über
die hälfte der deutschen bevölkerung
mittlerweile gepustet ist dass es eine
sehr gute entwicklung wir sehen hier
auch ein schnelles vorangehen das müssen
wir weiter ausbauen deswegen ist diese
impfkampagne die herr bundeskanzler
vorgestellt hat natürlich auch für
unsere kommunikation in den ländern sehr
hilfreich und wir werden alles daran
setzen dass entsprechend voranzubringen
berlin hat ja auf das boostern aber auch
auf die impfung von kindern und
jugendlichen einen ganz großen
schwerpunkt gesetzt wir konnten sehr
sehr große zahlen damit schon erreichen
und setzen auch weiterhin eben auf das
aufsuchende impfen auf das kinder und
familien impfen damit wir eben menschen
auch dort erreicht wo sie sind und auch
diejenigen erreichen die wir bisher noch
nicht erreichen konnten ich finde
wichtig dass wir heute sehr klar auch
gesagt haben zu den konkreten einzel
details gibt es verabredungen mit den
fachexperten mit den
gesundheitsministerinnen und ministern
um eben ein neues konzept für die
kontakt nachverfolgung und für das test
regime auszuarbeiten wir denken dass das
sehr zeitnah passieren würde dass es
dann auch die entsprechende orientierung
dafür gibt insofern haben wir heute sehr
konkrete verabredungen getroffen und
auch sehr einvernehmlich getroffen und
das auch in einem zeitrahmen der glaube
ich absolut vertretbar ist insofern
möchte ich auch danken einen kolleginnen
und kollegen die heute dazu beigetragen
haben dass wir diese vereinbarung auch
treffen konnten
verdanken das habe ich schon eine ganze
reihe von fragen und ich beginne mit
kristina dunz vom rnb und danach andreas
kinos von zdf vielen dank eine nachfrage
zunächst an herrn wüst sie haben gesagt
es geht nicht um schuldzuweisungen bei
dem mangel an test kapazitäten aber
woran hat es gelegen ist das noch in der
verantwortung des höheren cdu
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen der
ist nicht mehr geschafft hat oder karl
lauterbach von der spd es noch nicht
geschafft hat oder warum haben andere
länder mehr kapazitäten als wir und der
bundeskanzler wenn ich das jetzt auf die
schnelle in dem beschluss gesehen habe
ist eine formulierung nicht drin bei der
digitalisierung des gesundheitssystems
da ging es um die systematische
erfassung datenerfassung zur impfung
verbirgt sich dahinter ein impf register
oder warum gibt es protokollerklärung zb
aus baden württemberg die das explizit
nochmal einfordern vielen dank
von uns wenn ich sage dass ich mich als
schuldzuweisung nicht beteiligen will
dann meine ich das auch so was einfach
jetzt nichts bringen der blick nach
vorne hilft das mag in der vergangenheit
systemische entscheidung gegeben haben
die jetzt kapazitätseinschränkungen
sozusagen system ist bedingen das mag
alles sein wir haben auch sehr gesetzt
auf die schnelltests die den
steuerzahler auch eine menge geld
gekostet haben in den vergangenen
monaten
jetzt sind die pcr tests wir brauchen
mehr und wir sind uns alle einig dass
wir uns da anstrengend
sondern diese anstrengung werden derzeit
vernommen das geht ja darum auch private
unternehmen davon zu überzeugen dass sie
ihre test kapazitäten ausweiten
anders als in anderen ländern nennen das
nicht immer privatwirtschaftlich
organisiertes ist dass unsere aufgabe
und daran hat sich der bundesminister
für gesundheit auch gemacht die
konkrete frage betrifft die
digitalisierung des gesundheitswesens
die wollen wir voranbringen das
expertengremium battle sehr klar gesagt
wir sollten jetzt all das was wir in
dieser pandemie gelernt haben nutzen um
einen großen digitalisierung schub für
das gesamte gesundheitswesen auf den weg
zu bringen insbesondere natürlich auch
im zusammenhang mit dem was man
für eine pandemie braucht aber nicht nur
und ganz klar sind sich alle und darum
sind die formulierung auch so
ausgefallen wie sie sind das die frage
einer impfpflicht über die wir auch
schon diskutiert haben sich nicht
verknüpft wird dieser frage ob er welche
digitalisierung schritte werden
einzelnen vornehmen wollen und deshalb
geht es jetzt zügig voran und da wollte
keiner falsche assoziationen setzen ihre
nachfrage hat wahrscheinlich alle belegt
dass das vielleicht eine gute idee war
es ist klar dass wir digitalisierung
brauchen wie das konkret gemacht wird
darüber wird jetzt mit vielen experten
experten gesprochen und es ist eine
debatte die sich überhaupt nicht mit dem
anderen thema verknüpft das ja in jedem
fall etwas ist das man über längere zeit
aufbauen muss und wo es darum geht die
perfekte lösung zu finden die uns den
notwendigen informationen liefert und
gleichzeitig den
sicherheit der bürger hat bürger und
ihres nachfolgers
bundeskanzler herr wüst hat gerade über
parteiübergreifend kritik berichtet
darüber wie die verkürzung des genesenen
status von sechs auf drei monate
kommuniziert wurde oder besser gesagt
nicht kommuniziert wurde sie haben jetzt
gesagt ist müsse in zukunft zeit sein
sich darauf einzustellen wie viel zeit
ist damit gemeint in der
beschlussvorlage war von zwei wochen die
rede ist dass jetzt auch das worauf sie
sich geeinigt haben und haben sie ihren
gesundheitsminister gegen die
parteiübergreifende kritik von der herr
wüst spricht in dieser sitzung
verteidigt heute es gab eine sehr
solidarische diskussion wo alle sich vor
allem nach vorne gerichtet unterhalten
haben deshalb ist es auch so dass wir
keine konkrete zeitperspektive für die
frage welchen vorlauf brauchen sie für
jede einzelne entscheidung genannt haben
weil das in jedem einzelfall sehr
unterschiedlich sein kann es kann und
mit der man nicht rechnen situationen
geben die erfordern das sofort geahndet
werden muss aber sofort auch alle
informiert werden auch alle politischen
entscheidungsträger weil sich dramatisch
etwas ändert das keinen aufschub kostet
aufschub erlaubt und es kann situationen
geben wo wir durchaus noch die zeit
haben einen vorlauf prozess zu
organisieren
der aber sich dann auch jeweils aus der
natur der sache ergibt und in dieser
pragmatischen und konstruktive weise ist
die diskussion dann zu einem gemeinsamen
beschluss vorangekommen
der bundesgesundheitsminister hat von
mir die unterstützung bekommen die er
braucht und die auch kriegen muss weil
er ein ganz großartiger minister ist und
in dieser frage hoch engagiert und es
hat eigentlich jeder gesagt dass er sehr
engagiert diese arbeit macht ich glaube
sogar parteiübergreifend lässt sich das
festhalten insofern war ich vielleicht
geht man das besonders gerne gemacht hat
aber viele andere auch noch
die kollegin dahinter
farhadi hauptstadtstudio ich grüße sie
eine frage zur beschluss zum beschluss
dass darin steht dass beim
überregionalen
großveranstaltungen einheitliche regeln
beschlossen werden oder gesprochen
werden sollen heißt das also welche
richtung soll ausgehen heißt es gibt es
jetzt einheitlich bundesweit mehr
zuschauer bei fußballspielen oder
weniger
und die frage was heißt denn lockerungen
es wird von einer öffnung perspektive
gesprochen ein ende von 2g einer masken
pflichten ende wird dann vielleicht
irgendwann wieder eine normalität wie
vor der pandemie eintreten
was die letzte frage betrifft hofften
wir alle arbeiten wir alle hart daran
dass wir eine unsere lebenswirklichkeit
vor der pandemie wiederfinden werden
klar werden wir all das was wir jetzt
gelernt haben nicht vergessen
insbesondere die gefahr dass die welt in
der wir leben immer wieder solche
dramatischen negativen überraschungen
für uns bereit halten kann und auch neue
ihren neue infektionen einfluss nehmen
können wir unser leben nicht nur
hierzulande so und der ganzen welt und
darf müssen wir uns natürlich gut
vorbereitet trotzdem wir wollen wieder
zudem leben vor der pandemie
zurückkehren darum geht es ja bei all
dem was wir an anstrengungen unternehmen
und gleichzeitig gilt was ich und auch
die beiden die ihr neben mir sitzen
schon gesagt haben wir wollen jetzt
nicht den eindruck erwecken als ob das
jetzt der moment für lockerung werde das
ist ja nicht jetzt geht es um kurs
halten wir haben infektionszahlen die
höher sind als für sie sehr sehr als wir
sie bisher überhaupt verzeichnet haben
wir wissen dass diese infektionszahlen
noch höher werden dass also die ansteckt
das amt die ansteckende natur des nikon
virus dazu führen wird dass wir
möglicherweise sogar einmal daten mit
mehreren hunderttausend anstecken an
einem tag erleben und deshalb ist das
jetzt nicht der moment wo man sagt ja ja
sondern das ist im moment wo man kurz
hält klar ist dass wenn wir mehr wissen
land sehen denn wir wissen wo wir
hinkommen werden und wie wir durch die
situation kommen und sich die lage
entspannt dann auch über entscheidung
getroffen werden kann wie wir lockerung
vornehmen können das ist dann
darüber haben sich die
ministerpräsidenten
ministerpräsidenten intensiv unterhalten
und sind zu dem gemeinsamen ergebnis
gekommen ich glaube das kann man
zusammenfassen dass sie druck
auf gemeinsame zahlen und werte kommen
werden
michael fischer dpa als nächstes und
danach kerstin gerne leben von der seite
wir haben vielen dank herr bundeskanzler
sie haben gerade selbst den schleppenden
fortschritt erwähnt wir haben sich für
ende januar zwei ziele gesetzt dazu
einmal 30 millionen impfungen seit dem
dezember
und eine impfquote von 80 prozent bei
den erst impfung wir sind jetzt bei
ungefähr 15 millionen impfungen und 75,5
prozent bei den erste impfungen glauben
sie dass ihre ziele noch erreichbar sind
und das bedeutet ist für die die
impfpflicht für die debatte über die
impfpflicht die jetzt ansteht
und wenn sie erlauben noch eine frage
zum thema ukraine die eu-außenminister
haben heute der ukraine unterstützung
bei der militärausbildung in aussicht
gestellt wäre deutschland bereit sich
daran zu beteiligen
also zunächst mal ist es so dass wir
einen fortschritt haben der nicht gut
genug ist wir sind wie sie gesagt haben
bei erste impfung jetzt bei knapp über
75 prozent der bevölkerung wir müssen
viel höher liegen wir haben das ziel
weiter voranzukommen das geschieht auch
aber nicht in dem tempo das notwendig
wäre und was die auffrischungsimpfung
betrifft ist es so dass wir
uns vorgenommen haben dass wir hier
auch weiter vorankommen wir hatten vor
weihnachten zahlen mit über einer
million impfungen das ist gegenwärtig
nicht der fall und deshalb werden unsere
anstrengungen verstärkt werden müssen
damit wir weiter vorankommen mein ziel
bleibt dass wir all diejenigen die schon
eine auffrischungsimpfung haben
erreichen da die schon eine zweite
impfung haben sie schon vollständigen
impfschutz haben erreichen dass sie sich
eine auffrischungsimpfung holen dh das
ziel mit den 60 millionen bleibt man
muss realistisch sein das werden wir
nicht mehr zielgerecht erreichen in dem
tag wo ich mir das wünschen würde aber
wir haben durchaus die chance das ziel
zu erreichen und deshalb gilt es jetzt
hier auch entsprechend voranzukommen
darum auch die kampagne und ansonsten
ist es so dass wir natürlich
unterstützung zur verfügung stellen dass
es ja auch in der vergangenheit der fall
und die einzige sache die wir immer sehr
klar gesagt haben so wie auch die
frühere bundesregierung ist wir liefern
keine legalen waffen ansonsten hat das
kooperation unterstützung in der
vergangenheit gegeben und wird es auch
in zukunft gegeben auch mit unseren
freunden zusammen
ich würde gerne mal und sätzlich
angehen lassen sie haben ja heute kurz
bevor die dkg pressekonferenz angefangen
hat hat man gehört dass in berlin die
präsenzpflicht an schulen ausgesetzt
wird sie haben ausgeführt dass zu wenig
tests da sind das priorisiert wird die
arbeitgeber beschwerten sich dass sie
jetzt nicht mehr wissen auf welcher
grundlage sie möglicherweise entgelte
zahlen können und
die kontakt verfolgung bei den
gesundheitsämtern ist quasi aufgegeben
ist das jetzt nicht alles auch ein
eingeständnis dass sie die kontrolle
über die pandemie verloren haben und die
jetzt in den nächsten wochen durch
rauschen wird
nein aber es ist ein hinweis darauf und
deshalb bin ich ihm für die frage auch
sehr dankbar dass wir sehr hohe
infektionszahlen haben infektionszahlen
wie wir sie bisher nicht gekannt haben
wo wir schon ein bisschen zuschauern
konnten die sich das entwickeln wird in
unseren nachbarländern weil die ja
weniger strenge regeln was kontakt
beschriebenen betrifft ergriffen haben
und deshalb auch viel früher mit höheren
infektionszahlen durch das omikron virus
konfrontiert worden sind wir haben diese
zeit nutzen können dafür dass wir
weitermachen mit dem impfen dass wir bei
den auffrischungsimpfungen sicherlich
vorne anliegen in der europäischen union
und das wollen wir auch weitermachen und
auch wenn unsere eigenen ehrgeizigen
ziele dabei noch nicht erreicht sind
bleibt das ja dabei dass wir diese ziele
verfolgen aus gutem grund der hat
nämlich was mit den hohen
infektionszahlen zu tun und natürlich
muss man dann in einer konkreten
situation sich jeweils auf die situation
einstellen also die ohne
infektionszahlen führen dazu dass die
art und weise wie wir kann themen der
regeln festlegen sich verändern müssen
allerdings auch unsere wachsenden
erkenntnisse darüber wann eine
quarantäne verlassen werden kann wer da
wir haben zum beispiel auch die
möglichkeiten die sich dadurch ergeben
dass kontaktpersonen gebucht sind das
nutzen wir auch und das gleiche gilt für
die verschiedenen anderen entscheidungen
die wir im hinblick auf die
priorisierung zu treffen haben und über
die nutzung der konkreten tests
erforderlich sind meine these ist also
das ist eine große herausforderung und
bleibt auch eine all diejenigen die das
jetzt klein reden und sagen das sind
zwar hohe infektionszahlen aber es ist
nicht so haben sich recht aber wir haben
glaube ich schon eine lage in der bund
und länder die richtigen entscheidungen
treffen können und auch die angemessenen
entscheidungen für die konkrete
situation
gern was ergänzen zur schulischen
situation für uns ist und ich glaube
dass es sehr wichtig dass wir das auch
noch mal klar machen wir haben uns ja im
in der mpk darauf verständigt dass die
schulischen fragen in den jeweiligen
bundesländern geklärt werden anhand auch
das konkreten infektionsgeschehen in der
kultusminister zuständigkeit der länder
für uns und für mich ist es ganz wichtig
dass wir aufrechterhalten der schulische
angebot das alle kinder und jugendlichen
in die schule gehen können dass die
schulen geöffnet sind dass sie die
möglichkeit haben eben gut gebildet gut
betreut zu sein ein regelmäßiges
mittagessen zu bekommen und auch
entsprechend einen test zu bekommen wir
sehen aber in der situation die wir
haben mit den zunehmenden steigenden
zahlen dass wir auch eltern haben die
sich sorgen machen und die gerne diese
entscheidung ob sie ihr kind in die
schule schicken oder nicht auch selbst
treffen möchten und diese
diese entscheidung die wir jetzt
getroffen haben zu sagen wir setzen
temporär die präsenzpflicht in den
berliner schulen aus bis ende februar
die basiert auf der erklärung der
als ärzte in den gesundheitsämtern dass
sie eben eine kontakt nach verfolgung in
allen über 800 touren bei über 300.000
schülerinnen und schülern nicht mehr so
nach voll verfolgen nachvollziehen
können und in diesem moment wo wir eine
solche situation haben solche fallzahlen
haben ist eben auf der einen seite für
uns wichtig dass wir den schulbetrieb
aufrecht erhalten dass es ein angebot
weiter gibt aber dass gleichzeitig auch
den eltern die möglichkeit eingeräumt
wird wenn sie es möchten und für sich
und ihr kind entscheiden wie sich eine
ausnahme von dieser präsenz aufzunehmen
und das ganz unkompliziert ab morgen
auch machen zu können trotzdem ist für
uns wichtig die schulen bleiben offen
dass präsenz angebot ist das
regelangebot auch weiterhin es gibt die
möglichkeit davon abzuweichen
aber ich glaube das ist einfach jetzt
ein weg um den verschiedenen
bedürfnissen die wir hier an dieser
stelle sehen kinderbetreuung
aufrechterhalten auf der anderen seite
den sorgen der eltern zu entsprechen
auch hier gerecht zu werden und das ist
ein zeichen von reaktion sofort der
reaktion auf eine veränderte lage und
das ist glaube ich das auch von uns
erwartet würden das hat nichts mit
kontrollverlust zu tun sondern damit
dass wir einfach gezwungen sind auf die
sich aktuell ändernde entwicklung auf zu
reagieren und einzugehen so dass es für
möglichst viele in der bevölkerung auch
ein gangbarer weg ist und darum geht es
an der stelle
ja noch ein paar nachfragen auch an den
bundeskanzler die nachfrage
würden sie sagen dass sie trotz dieser
sagen wir mal eigenverantwortlich
handelnden infizierten bürger trotz
mangelnder test trotz rudimentäre
kontakt verfolgung die übersicht über
die infektionszahlen beiden werden
dafür sind heute die notwendigen
entscheidungen getroffen worden genau
das passiert darum haben wir das
expertengremium und dann haben wir den
krisenstab darum nehmen wir die
ratschläge an und darum gibt es die
entscheidung die zum beispiel die
gesundheitsministerin als minister der
länder mit dem bundesgesundheitsminister
getroffen haben und die jetzt auch hier
sich in dem beschluss den verschiedenen
stellen wieder film es ist die richtige
reaktion auf eine veränderte lage und
das ist gut dass das so einvernehmlich
so koordiniert so gut vorbereitet und so
lange diskutiert geschieht weil das die
voraussetzung dafür ist dass wir
jederzeit das richtige in der lage tun
könnten
andreas rinke und danach vegetieren
dankeschön eine frage sowohl an den
kanzler als auch an herrn grüßt und zwar
zu dem passus wo es auch um mögliche
verschärfungen geht wenn eine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems droht
so die formulierung woran wird das genau
gemessen werden also haben sie da
bestimmte indikatoren die sie dann dafür
heranziehen oder sollen die
krankenhäuser erst etwas flapsig gesagt
verlaufen wie der expertenrat das jahr
prognostiziert und herr bundeskanzler
auch eine frage zu kleine das weiße haus
hat bekannt gegeben dass sie nachher an
einer videoseite teilnehmen mit der
europäischen staats und regierungschefs
und dem us-präsidenten ist das ein
zeichen dafür dass die lage so
besorgniserregend geworden ist dass sie
über notfall und sanktionsmaßnahmen
nachdenken müssen
zur zweiten frage die lage ist ernst
aber nicht erst heute sondern seinen
vielen vielen tagen wochen und monaten
schon und deshalb ist es auch richtig
dass wir in dieser frage alle einig und
geschlossen handeln und dazu gehört dass
wir sagen es darf nicht zu einer
verletzung der territorialen integrität
eines staates in europa kommen das gilt
ganz besonders auch für die ukraine
und wir werden das auch nicht hinnehmen
und falls es zu einer solchen situation
kommt werden wir gemeinsam reagieren das
würde hohe kosten haben
aber es gehört auch zu dieser situation
dass wir sie immer wieder gemeinsam
bewerten die lage besprechen und daraus
die nächsten schritte ableiten die wir
mit den dazu treffen haben insofern ist
das ein gutes zeichen für die enge
zusammenarbeit und die gute kooperation
unter denjenigen die sich hier zusammen
treibt die hier zusammentreffen aber
insgesamt für nato und europäische union
ich glaube dass man das so bewerten
sollte
was die frage betrifft
nach den maßnahmen die ergriffen werden
müssen und woran der das messen wir
haben doch jetzt eine situation die
hätte in keinem wissenschaftler und
keine wissenschaftlerin als die
situation
am anfang des jahres 2021 vorher gesagt
dass wir sehr hohe infektionszahlen
haben wir in anderen ländern wo sie
teilweise ein paar hunderttausend bürger
pro tag betreffen länder die
vergleichbar sind mit uns da sind wir
nicht angekommen wir sind jetzt aber
über den 100000 auch schon an
verschiedenen tagen gewesen und werden
das auch weiter sein es wird weiter
steigende infektionszahlen geben
trotzdem hätte niemand vorher gesagt
dass mit diesen hohen infektionszahlen
nicht in gleicher weise wie früher eine
belastung der krankenhäuser insgesamt
und insbesondere der intensivstation
verbunden ist bisher wir wissen aber
dass
durch die große zahl der infizierten
das schon eine herausforderung ist und
die auf das gesundheitswesen zukommt und
deshalb ist ja unsere klare entscheidung
wir bereiten uns auf eine solche
situation vor ja können hoffen
dass das verhältnis zwischen infektionen
und intensiv leichtigkeit
so viel geringer ist dass das nicht
passieren wird wir können hoffen dass
unsere fortgesetzte impf und auch auf
richtungs kampagne mit dem muster
impfung dazu beiträgt dass wir die
situation dadurch entlasten können und
deshalb kann niemand gegenwärtig
vorhersagen welche der verschiedenen
möglichen entwicklungen und tatsächlich
in deutschland eintreten wird wir tun
alles dafür dass es diejenigen die die
weniger herausfordernde
situation mit sich bringt wie es dann
kommen wird das eis kann er jetzt und
das kann man auch nicht vorhersagen
vielleicht ergänzen berlin noch da noch
sagen es ist ja auch den zweiten faktor
gibt der 2 belastung des
gesundheitssystems führen kann nämlich
eine große anzahl von erkrankten
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern und
das haben wir natürlich sehr genau im
blick weil die ja tagesaktuell in den
kliniken bekannt sind herr professor
krömer hat das sollte auch für die
charité
berichtet dass man sozusagen tages genau
sagen kann wie viele mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeiter erkranken wo wir merkt gar
nicht nur im dienst überwiegend sogar je
nach beschäftigung außerhalb des
krankenhauses und beides muss man im
blick haben den anfall von patienten
aber auch den ausfall von
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern durch
eigene infektion oder durch garantien
ja ich hatte auch noch mal eine frage
zur eröffnungs perspektive ist denn
schon diskutiert werden welche bereiche
man eventuell als ersten schritt öffnen
könnte und dann das der nächste termin
ist der 16 februar
der gesundheitsminister sagt dass dann
ungefähr auch der der höhepunkt der
pandemie erreicht sein könnte könnte man
denn dann vielleicht auch schon
entscheiden ob man dann in einer
lockerung 1 1 geht wenn man erkennt dass
letztendlich da keine überlastung ist
und auch noch mal eine frage zur ukraine
es gibt ja sicherlich auch unter anderem
auch um die frage ob andere länder
waffen oder auch ausrüstung liefern
estland hatte eben eine solche anfrage
gestellt ist die bundesregierung bereit
letztendlich diese lieferung zu
ermöglichen
sie kennen die entscheidung die
bundesregierung
kontinuität waffen die von getroffen hat
hier so etwas andere sachverhalte noch
geprüft wird und das dauert auch noch an
was die frage betrifft
der
beschäftigung mit lockerungen das wäre
glaube ich in der gegenwärtigen
situation und etwas eigentlich wenn wir
da konkrete diskussion über konkrete
maßnahmen führen würden denn wir erleben
ja gerade neue hochs bei den
infektionszahlen und wir wissen dass
weitere hochs auf uns zukommen werden
sie selbst haben gerade gesagt dass es
so sein kann dass die
ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten
der regierungschef von regierungschefs
der länder mit dem bundeskanzler das
nächste mal zusammenkommen am 16 februar
wahrscheinlich gerade der höhepunkt des
infektionsgeschehen zu verzeichnen ist
nach den berechnungen die gegenwärtig
angestellt werden wie es dann sein wird
wissen wir am 16 februar genauer und
deshalb macht es auch keinen sinn
irgendwelche vorhersagen oder das was
wir konkret an dem tag zu beraten haben
zu treffen es gehört schon dazu dass wir
die wirkliche lage betrachten und dann
mit realen entscheidung auf die
wirklichen lage reagieren
burke von der deutschen welle ich möchte
auch zu der ukraine krise vor allem den
bundeskanzler fragen herr bundeskanzler
die äußerungen von dem marine inspekteur
in indien zu der krise in ukraine haben
natürlich für entsetzen gesorgt vor
allem in ukraine er ist natürlich nicht
mehr im amt aber seine äußerungen sind
für viele ausländische betrachter
besonders über beispielsweise in ukraine
grund zur sorge dass seine haltung in
deutschland vielleicht sogar in ihrer
partei weit verbreitet ist deswegen für
das internationale publikum die frage
wie bewerten sie als bundeskanzler
persönlich die äußerungen von kay achim
schönbach und auch also zu dieser frage
bezüglich es land würde ich mich auch
anschließen diese entscheidung dauert an
haben sie gesagt aber was wäre ihre
meinung also was würden sie sind sie
persönlich dafür oder dagegen
dankeschön
prüfungs entscheidungen prüfungs
entscheidung denn sorgfältig die
verschiedenen fragen abgewogen werden
übrigens nicht nur von der deutschen
regierung da sind auch andere dann
beteiligt sogar vor uns und das ist
alles noch ganz am anfang dass wir
darüber jetzt zu diesem zeitpunkt
diskutieren ist eher unwahrscheinlich da
waren einige dicht dran an einem
entscheidungsprozess der noch nicht mal
begonnen hatte und haben schon über ihn
berichtet das ist natürlich interessant
vielleicht auch für die
selbstbeobachtung aber die zweite frage
die
aussagen die der
pizza hat mir halt gemacht hat
entsprechen nicht den vorstellungen der
bundesregierung und deshalb ist er auch
seine demission akzeptiert
wie lang
ich einen guten heimweg
ja und das war also die pressekonferenz
unter anderem mit dem bundeskanzler mit
olaf scholz mit franziska giffey der
regierenden bürgermeisterin von berlin
und natürlich auch mit hendrik wüst dem
vorsitzenden der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
fast nur ganz kurz zusammen was olaf
scholz gesagt hat in bezug auf die
korona maßnahmen sagte er dass der kurs
stimme er würde auch ebenso fortgesetzt
werden strenge kontakt beschränkungen
müssen bleiben denn sie haben die
infektionszahlen lange zeit aufgehalten
noch besteht eine gewisse unsicherheit
in bezug auf die entwicklung mit
umgekommen aber
man will sich da jedenfalls kein allzu
großes risiko leisten sondern man will
eben da lieber auch vorsichtig weiter
machen das impf tempo habe
bedauerlicherweise
nachgelassen deswegen werde die
bundesregierung die kampagne auch die
werbekampagne um die impfkampagne jetzt
wieder in gang zu bringen auch nochmals
intensivieren es gab noch ein paar
andere punkte dazu vielleicht dann
gleich noch mehr ansonsten noch ganz
kurz hendrik wüst er hat sich auch noch
mal dahinter gestellt er sagte ja der
expertenrat hätte ja auch die empfehlung
ausgesprochen dass die maßnahmen so im
großen und ganzen beibehalten werden
sollen änderungen könne es geben bei
änderungen der lage sowohl richtung
verschärfungen aber auch in richtung
erleichterung man müsse das ganze im
blick behalten ähnlich auch franziska
giffey und auch sie hat noch mal betont
dass
es eben eine erforderlichkeit gibt das
test regime zu ändern dass der neue
prioritäten gesetzt werden müssen
angesichts der mangelnden kapazitäten
aber sie hat auch nochmal an die
eigenverantwortlichkeit der bürgerinnen
und bürger appelliert wie man sich in
der pandemie doch am besten verhalten
soll das dass jeder auch noch mal für
sich selbst überlegt und sich dann
entsprechend auch verhält so dass
sprechen wir darüber auch nochmal mit
nicole diekmann mit unserer kolleginnen
aus dem hauptstadtstudio nicole gab es
für dich dann irgendwie überraschungen
bei dem was du jetzt gerade gehört hast
ich finde man ist überraschend eng an
der beschlussvorlage geblieben die wir
ja auch im vorfeld schon hatten also gab
es keine überraschungen großartig
interessant war die verteilung
die rollenverteilung das ist ja auch
immer wichtiger punkt bei diesen
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen
beziehungsweise nach den
pressekonferenzen nach dem
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen und olaf
scholz war dafür da noch mal zu sagen
wir bleiben bei unserem kurs wörtlich
hatte er gesagt jetzt geht erstmal kurs
halten
hat nochmal die unterschiedlichen punkte
video auch gerade auf geführt hast
genannt dann kam hendrik wüst
anders als scholz kein spd politiker
sondern ein cdu-politiker
der tatsächlich kurz auf das thema im
und genießen den status eingehen wir
beide haben ja vorhin vor der
pressekonferenz auch schon mal darüber
gesprochen es gab großen unmut auch
gegenüber dem gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach ebenso wie olaf scholz und
würdigung mitglied der spd
anders als hendrik wüst cdu
war ja
sehr spontan von 180 tagen auf 90 tagen
gültigkeit herabgestuft wurde durch das
lka das robert-koch-institut dass
lauterbach untersteht
und da sagte hendrik wüst es sei
intensiv in dieser mpk darüber noch
einmal gesprochen worden das
wortwörtlich sich das nicht wiederholen
darf das war sehr deutlich ein
seitenhieb also auf den spd
gesundheitsminister von einem
wahlkämpfenden nrw ministerpräsidenten
in nordrhein westfalen wo wüst regiert
und gerne weiter regieren möchte wird im
mai gewählt also parteipolitik war heute
auch bei und dann kam franziska die
wiederum auch der spd angehört und
franziska giffey wenn man franziska
gehört hat dann gibt es eigentlich
zunächst eine alternative dann hat
niemand einen fehler gemacht bei der
beschaffung beziehungsweise der
organisation von ausreichend pc wir
wissen die sind nicht mehr ausreichend
vorhanden franziska giffey sagt da das
wort natürlich es sei anders nicht
möglich als jetzt geben ein test regime
ein anderes test regime zu erarbeiten es
gibt schlichtweg nicht genug pcr tests
aber wie gesagt das nicht laut franziska
giffey in der natur der sache und da
sind wir bei einem interessanten punkt
denn heute hat die große runde
arbeitsaufträge quasi verteilt für
dieses tests regime soll jetzt zuständig
sein der bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach der soll jetzt ein konzept
erarbeiten wie man mit dem was noch
vorhanden ist
vernünftig so will es die politik
natürlich verkaufen weiter testen kann
die concept nachverfolgung die ja auch
nicht mehr funktioniert auch da sagt
franziska giffey natürlich kann die
nicht funktionieren weil wir eben gerade
omikron haben und eine unglaubliche zahl
von neuinfektionen
da sind jetzt die gesundheitsminister da
ist die gesundheitsministerkonferenz
gefragt also das heißt also und dritter
und es ging auch um
großveranstaltungen da geht es ja vor
allem immer um fussballspiele da sollen
jetzt die einzelnen länder sich
zusammensetzen auch nochmal und eine
gemeinsame zahl das heißt die soll dann
in allen bundesländern gelten eine
höchstzahl von zuschauerinnen und
zuschauern die zugelassen sind eher
arbeiten also unterm strich man hat
heute beschlossen man macht erstmal so
weiter
was zb 2g plus regelungen masten pflicht
und so weiter angeht und man hat zwei
arbeitsaufträge nach außen gegeben ja
also du hast vorhin schon gesagt es gab
diesen gewissen rüssel für herrn
lauterbach in bezug auf eben die doch
relativ schnell eine änderung des
gelesenen status generell kann man
glaube ich schon sagen es war doch auch
eine große einigkeit vorhanden so dass
ja eventuell das was du vorhin
angesprochen hat ist also dass ich jetzt
wieder einer oder eine hinstellt und
sagt ich mache es aber doch ganz anders
in meinem land nicht unbedingt zu
erwarten ist oder würdest du so weit
nicht gehen
so weit würde ich nicht gehen weil wir
ja seit zwei jahren pandemie haben und
seit zwei jahren auch eine hohe
schlagzahl an ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen und da haben wir uns ja
öfter schon mal die augen gerieben ich
erinnere mich an einen fall da lief die
pressekonferenz damals noch unter angela
merkel damals als kanzlerin noch und
zeitgleich stellte sich ein
ministerpräsident vor die kameras und
sagte ja wir machen aber folgen das
anders also da ist jetzt heute nicht so
viel beschlossen worden wovon man
abweichen könnte aber abweichen geht
immer locker sieht immer rein
theoretisch auch wenn die zahlen es
nicht zulassen
ich würde da erstmal abwarten ich würde
jetzt keine wetten abschließen nicole
dann warten wir gemeinsam mit ihr ab
gedanken dir ganz herzlich für diese
einordnung heute abend und eine analyse
der ergebnisse und dessen was dort eben
entschieden worden ist dankeschön und
einen schönen abend nach berlin und wir
sind sehr froh dass wir doch noch mal
sprechen können auch mit professor hajo
cps uns nochmal zugeschaltet und auch
ihn
erreicht jetzt von mir sozusagen die
frage wie er denn die maßnahmen die da
jetzt eben beschlossen worden sind
bewertet es gab ja keine allzu großen
überraschungen wie haben sie die
pressekonferenz und die ergebnisse vor
allem aufgenommen
ja und das ist tatsächlich ja sehr nah
an dem was vorher bekannt war es ist
insgesamt doch schon wenn man einfach
von außen schaut ein bisschen
überraschen wir haben auf der einen
seite ja doch sich durchaus
dramatisierende lager was die
infektionszahlen angeht zwar sieht es
noch ganz gut in den krankenhäusern aus
aber die zahlen gehen schon sehr hoch
die politische reaktion die
infektionsschutz reaktion bleibt jetzt
aber erst mal im großen und ganzen
gleich mit ein paar anpassungen immer an
diese großen fallzahlen mit pcr tests
zum beispiel eben jetzt nicht mehr für
jede bestätigung eines schnelltests zum
beispiel oder andere umstände also wir
haben ein paar wenige änderungen bei
einer deutlich auf der anderen seite
sich verändernde lage da bin ich schon
gespannt wie das funktionieren würde ich
bin andererseits jetzt doch mittlerweile
ganze positiv gestimmt dass eben mit dem
expertenrat wo viele kolleginnen ja von
unseren kollegen zusammenarbeiten dann
doch auch in meine stimme vorher eine
rolle spielte die mithilft ja
entscheidung zu begründen und auch eine
gewisse
orientierung zu geben das ist glaube ich
mittlerweile ganz gut dass sich jetzt
aus meiner sicht als wissenschaftler
ganz positiv trotz allem bin ich auch
gespannt ob das reicht tatsächlich was
wir jetzt sehen und ob wir damit gut
durch die nächsten wenigen wochen kommen
ja da schwingt natürlich so ein leiser
zweifel schon im mit worauf wird es denn
aus ihrer sicht aus epidemiologischer
sicht an kommen jetzt in den nächsten
tagen und wochen was sollten wir alle
beherzigen
ja ich war uns alle gilt natürlich
tatsächlich
weiterhin sehr große vorsieht waren zu
lassen also wir müssen die natürlich
thematik des impfens weiterhin
vorantreiben da sind eine reihe von
vorschlägen ja auch zu bekommen ich da
würde ich allerdings sogar gerne noch
einen schritt zu legen wir müssten so
leicht haben noch über andere maßnahmen
nachdenken also noch mehr intensiviert
die impfungen zu den menschen hin
bringen wo sie wo sie leben noch mehr in
den diversität reingehen ich glaube da
kann man noch mehr machen das ist jetzt
eine kampagne noch einmal intensiviert
angekündigt aber der fortschritt ist da
ist da tatsächlich aus meiner sicht
nicht so wie er sein könnte und da haben
wir dann wirklich eine große lücke das
andere sind natürlich ja unser eigenes
verhalten kontakt beschränkung der
werden sich viele menschen schon auch
glaube ich noch eine zeit lang dran
halten jeder jede sieht was passiert im
moment sind viele zahlen die einen da
etwas kritisch stimmen können und viel
erleben es auch mir eigenen umfeld da
ist es jetzt andererseits wirklich die
frage der der kommunikation gerade jetzt
wo die veränderten regeln bei der
quarantäne da muss jetzt sehr klar
agiert werden damit nicht menschen
durcheinander kommen und sich fragen was
für ein test muss ich was
machen oder überhaupt noch einen test
das wird jetzt nicht einfach und ich
glaube da muss man wirklich viel
passieren damit das gut herüber kommt
was jetzt wichtig ist also auch die
impfung wieder sie sagten es näher an
die leute reinbringen das ist ja auch
immer wieder ein thema auch in
zusammenhang mit der impfpflicht und an
der stelle vielleicht der hinweis viele
fragen haben jetzt im moment nicht im
chat aber wir haben doch einige
kommentare die eben sich pro und contra
impfpflicht äußern vielleicht gerade
noch mal an sie die frage sie haben
gesagt ja also die das eben angebot muss
an die leute kommen wenn das immer noch
nicht ausreichend sein sollte wie stehen
sie eine allgemeine impfpflicht generell
gegenüber
es ist tatsächlich so dass ich genau
diese diese schritte sehr wir haben noch
nicht alles ausgereizt denke ich und das
sollte passieren und die barrieren
müssen sehr niedrig sein es muss
wirklich da ganz klar sein ist es für
jedermann eine einfache sache einen hut
zu bekommen ich weiß das ist eine ganze
menge personen gibt die dem sich
trotzdem nicht unterwerfen werden wie
sie es aus ihrer 16 und dann ist es wohl
so dass eine impfpflicht
nötig wird die ist jetzt nicht
überhastet nötig weil wir im moment der
mir kommen werde damit nicht aufgehalten
werden die ist vielleicht für die
zukunft dann nötig und da sollte jetzt
noch ein bisschen
automat diskutiert und nachgedacht
werden damit wieder auf breite beine
stellen die entscheidung die dann nötige
und dann bin ich auch für eine
impfpflicht
dankeschön vielleicht gerade noch mal
die nachfrage auch hier von kolja mac
wupper bei youtube könnten sie mal beim
expert nachfragen ob aus sicht des
ewigen ffp zwei masken pflicht im öpnv
au mehr sinn machen würde als die 3g
regel ft2 maske ansteckungsrisiko ist
doch damit im promillebereich so seine
auffassung also wie ist ihre
einschätzung massen pflicht versus 3g
regel
ja ich fürchte das ist nicht ganz
gegeneinander
abzuwägen beide ist es wichtig die
ersten sind schon sehr effektiv und
wirklich sehr sehr hilfreich und man
muss ja auch bei dreijährige bedenken
klar es wird ein test gemacht wenn man
als im mit 3g
ich bin frau unterwegs ist aber die
maske sind gibt da noch mal die
zusätzliche sicherheit denn wir wissen
alle die tests war die schnellste sind
jetzt nicht so überzeugend stark dass
sie in jedem fall sicherstellen können
es gibt keine infektion und wir fahren
natürlich dann auch geimpfte mit die
sich haben nicht testen lassen wir sind
dass auch wir haben um einen viele
infektionen auch bei geimpften dagegen
schützt die impfung jedenfalls die
zweifache impfung nicht ich denke man
braucht tatsächlich beides ermöglichen
fordern wird nicht gegeneinander
aufgewogen werden können letzte frage an
sie von mir sie sind kein politiker das
ist schon klar aber es wird immer mal
wieder die kritiker vorgebracht eben an
der aktuellen regierung die kontrolle
über die lage sei eventuell nicht mehr
so ganz vorhanden stichworte impfpflicht
und eben die ja sehr schleppend anläuft
dann überhaupt sind die fehlende test
kapazität wie sehen sie das würden sie
so weit gehen oder sagen sie näher das
ist schon so dass man noch sagen kann
das hat alles hand und fuß und baut
aufeinander auf und bewegen uns in die
richtige richtung
ja also jetzt sicher wie man zu beneiden
die entscheidung treffen muss das ist
ganz klar wir müssen da schon sehen wie
wenn man sich dann kommt das alles
passiert wie dynamisch sich die lager in
schon allein nach seit weihnachten
entwickelt hat also ich würde jetzt
moment nicht sagen ihr macht jemand
alles falsch es ist schwierig das ist
gar keine frage es ist aber auch
tatsächlich eine situation bei der 0
trotzdem möglichst klare entscheidung
getroffen werden müssen und da ist immer
gut dass ich hier offensichtlich die
politiker jetzt nicht mehr zuseher
streiten sondern doch sehr viel am
strand ziehen das scheint mir zumindest
um dann maßnahme umsetzen können ganz
wichtig zu sein aber
ich die kontrolle ist ganz ganz schwer
zu behalten im moment und ich wüsste
auch nicht was super gute beispiele auch
weltweit gibt dass das gelingt wir
können auch china schauen die kosten
dort immens das zu machen was dort
passiert und dennoch gelingt nicht alles
wir können andere länder schauen extrem
aufwendige aktivitäten locals strategien
umzusetzen auch das ist schwierig es ist
eine vertrackte lage und niemanden zu
ist hier zu beneiden die jetzige
politische
handlungsweise ist sicher optimierbar
gar keine frage professor hc war das
nochmal für uns vom leibniz-institut für
präventiv forschung und epidemiologie
vielen dank dass sie sich noch mal die
zeit genommen haben und uns noch mal zur
verfügung standen und einen schönen
abend noch mal danke sehr
so und wir wollen uns gerade noch mal
die ergebnisse anschauen zumindest ein
konkretes ergebnis der maßnahmen die
heute eben nochmal festgezurrt worden
sind da ging es noch mal um die pcr
tests und wir hatten das schon
angesprochen dass die test regelungen da
angepasst worden sind also die sollen
jetzt vorbehalten bleiben die pcr tests
nämlich den risikogruppen bzw
beschäftigten im klinik- und im
pflegebereich das also noch mal ein ganz
wichtiger hinweis da gab es wie gesagt
größere diskussionen weil es eben da
diese knappheit gibt und wir sind in der
glücklichen lage jetzt noch einmal zu
sprechen wenn ich das richtig sehe oder
kommt da noch mehr ausweitung der pcr
nein ich glaube das hat sich damit
erledigt aber hier haben wir unsere
nächste unserem nächsten gast doktor
lisa federle nämlich der eine oder die
andere wird sie schon gesehen haben im
fernsehen in der korona panini besonders
engagierte und dafür auch unter anderem
mit dem bundesverdienstkreuz
ausgezeichnete medizinerin aus tübingen
und eben auch vielen schon aus den
medien als meinungsstarke frau bekannt
einen schönen guten abend frau federle
ich habe sie jetzt nicht gehört ich
hoffe sie können mich aber hören ich
fragte nochmals
wunderbar doch prima jetzt höre ich sie
auch ja wie fällt denn ihr kommentar aus
zur gegenwärtigen situation sie haben ja
auch mitbekommen was jetzt gerade eben
noch mal an maßnahmen verabschiedet
worden ist im wesentlichen bleiben die
ja erhalten beziehungsweise bei den
tests will man sich jetzt um eben wir
haben es gerade auch noch mal gezeigt um
eine andere priorisierung bemühen wie
bewerten sie das
also mich ärgert dass mit der anderen
priorisierung insofern dass wir das
nicht hätten machen müssen wenn wir uns
rechtzeitig darum gekümmert hätten
schauen wir mal in die andere länder
sind schlusslicht beim testen in europa
und seit anderthalb wir haben redet vom
testen und seit andere fragen haben
versuchen mich dafür einzusetzen
beispiel am zehnten januar diesen jahres
ist vom gesundheitsminister sind die pop
pcr tests so schlecht ab nächsten tag so
schlecht vergütet worden das dem ganzen
apotheker und auch
praxis eingestellt haben das sind pcr
adäquate test sie beim
gesundheitsministerium sogar ist und
empfohlen sind und da bezahlt die seit
dem elften auch ist elfter januar noch
nicht einmal mehr die sachkosten das
heißt wir haben viele kollegen des sagte
solche geräte hatten sie machen das
nicht mehr und jetzt überlegen sie sich
in dieser krise ist es extrem wichtig
wenn wir bestimmte person auch sofort
testen können das heißt nach 15 minuten
so sicher wie beim pca und so gilt es
weltweit denjenigen sagen können er kann
wieder zurück am arbeitsplatz in die
klinik den rettungsdienst oder
lehrerinnen die ich direkt wieder in die
schule schicken konnte ja nach falsch
negativen schnalzt ja frau niederländer
ist ganz interessant da würde ich gerne
noch mal einen haken weil das ist jetzt
vielleicht dieses verfahren auch nicht
jedem bekannt aber wir haben da ein paar
bilder vorbereitet vielleicht könnten
sie noch mal sagen was das für ein
testverfahren ist dass sie da anwenden
das ist ein test war es ist etwas
aufwendiger ich mache aber auch im nasen
und rachenabstriche
habe der test kostet circa 35 euro plus
mehrwertsteuer und ich brauche genau 15
minuten um den er demjenigen das
testergebnis weiterzugeben das wird
weltweit auch vom ak ii vom
bundesgesundheitsministerium und
trotzdem ist sind diese tests so gekürzt
worden dass wir die eigentlich nur noch
ehrenamtlich sozusagen ausführen können
wir machen das in tübingen ich habe
diese tests und seit april letzten
jahres immer praxis benutze die ständig
und ich kann nicht verstehen dass genau
jetzt so kurzfristig die auch noch so
reduziert worden sind also es ist mir
echt ein rätsel das ist einfach ein
faux-pas sorgen tut mir leid und ich
finde man kann nicht immer sagen es
helfen keine schuldzuweisungen
irgendwann müssen wir doch mal geklaut
haben dass wir eben testen testen testen
müssen und wir wussten dass es auf uns
zukommt warum gelingt es anderen leben
von uns nicht und ich finde es auch
nicht sehr beispielsweise jetzt nur
risikogruppen fest lassen zu können es
gibt natürlich auch leute für die ist es
prozent eminent wichtig vielleicht wenn
ich meine großmutter besuchen und haben
positiven schnelltest und kann es dann
nicht weil er weiß sehr schlecht geht
oder sonst hast dann brauche ich so
möglichst schnell in pcr test und
deswegen auch warte ich dass wir sofort
genau solche dinge wieder rückgängig
machen und schauen dass wir die tests
herkriegen und zwar überall mehr aus so
schnell wie möglich also der klarer
appell von ihnen dass es eben doch mehr
pcr tests in deutschland geben müsste
die dann eben auch schnell zur verfügung
gestellt werden müssten und zwar allen
mehr oder weniger die einen brauchen
wobei sie da jetzt den kreis dann schon
groß machen würden also da jetzt nicht
nur fachpersonal oder dergleichen oder
leute die
wohlhabenden gruppen angehören
natürlich ich meine das machen andere
länder auch die chance nach österreich
ich meine das jetzt vielleicht extrem zu
warum das nicht haben aber das ist
einfach das wird nicht funktionieren das
haben sie sehen was waren die leute die
trinken reisen müssen es gibt ja
schließlich doch auch noch den einen
oder anderen der wand aus den usa es
gibt viele viele berufe die vielleicht
jetzt nicht nicht gerade unter erster
fahren aber trotzdem wichtig sind also
wir haben dann sehr sehr viele berufe
die trotzdem existenz sehr wichtig sind
und ich muss apotheken zum beispiel oder
was auch immer also ich muss wirklich
sagen wenn du da mitzumachen und ich
erwarte auch dass das wirklich gemacht
wird das wird so schnell wie möglich die
sind es wieder machen können wie gesagt
wir machen es trotzdem nichts praktisch
ich habe nur alles für die stadt und der
landrat unterstützt
sie haben das gerät wenn ich richtig
weißt du auf eigene kosten angeschafft
ja letztes jahr im april und des drk es
auch angeschafft und jetzt sagen es
ihnen einfaches beispiel gerade jetzt wo
wir erwarten dass die zahlen zu
schreiben steigen ja wenn einer bei uns
schlucken hat im rettungsdienst oder von
mir aus den anderen positiven schneit es
wir können den 15 minuten sagen ob er
positiv ist oder nicht und dann können
wir ihn wieder einsetzen oder wir
schicken ihnen nach hause und das ist
effektiv
das klingt jedenfalls sehr effektiv und
ich kann gut nachvollziehen dass sie da
verärgert sind also um sie jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen zu beruhigen
falls sie das beruhigt also das war ja
schon dann auch jetzt der tenor auf
dieser pressekonferenz sowohl vom bund
als auch von ländern dass die test
kapazitäten schnellstmöglich wieder
ausgebaut werden soll aber es wird mit
sicherheit eine weile dauern bis es dann
wieder genug tests gibt
ich fürchte dass es zu sein dort aber
das problem ist auch hier haben wir
ärzte oder auch die apotheker werden
lange nicht erfahren dass dort wieder
dauern bis wir wissen können wir jetzt
durchführen oder müssen die selber
zahlen und es geht nicht jeder gabe so
ein risiko ich meine dass es trotzdem
eine keine kleine summe insofern sollte
die schöpfung bieten das tempo jetzt
rein kommt und deswegen setze ich mich
auch so dafür ein in sechs wochen
brauchen das zeigt vielleicht nicht mehr
und das wasser auf zu sagen ja oder sich
das ist die frage genau was dann noch
brauchen werden ich stelle vielleicht
noch mal ein zwei user fragen oder leute
die an sie weiter knuspern sie bei
youtube wenn sich viele boostern lassen
und die impfverweigerer in einer großen
zahl sich weiterhin nicht impfen lassen
ist es doch zwangsläufig so dass das
impfen insgesamt langsamer wird die
frage ob ich die frage richtig
verstanden habe ich weiß ob sie damit
etwas anfangen können sehen sie das auch
so
habe ich jetzt auch verstanden aber ich
bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher sein ob
die märkte pustet sind umso weniger
brauchen sich noch impfen lassen ja ist
eigentlich herzlich von sein oder so
genau dann hat sie es im prinzip von
alleine geklärt pillepalle fans über
youtube wiesn gibt es im privatbereich
immer mehr regeln jedoch auf der können
20 mann oder eben auch frauen ohne maske
oder einschränkungen in einem pausenraum
sitzen dass seine frage so beobachtet er
oder sie das offenbar würden sie den
musiker
ich glaube es hat sich nicht alle leute
an die regeln das ist die eine seite die
andere seite ist dass viele dinge bei
uns unlogisch laufen ja also bei spielen
jetzt um noch mal kurz zum testen
zurückzukommen wir haben die die
den genesenen status der ist auf drei
monate runtergesetzt wurden ja von einem
tag auf den anderen was machen sie denn
jetzt wenn sie jetzt positiv sind wir
wollen sie denn nachweisen wenn sie nur
um schnell test dafür zur verfügung
bekommen ob sie genesen sind oder nicht
und sich dann einfach nicht mehr post
und lassen müssen weil sie nämlich
gerade wieder genesen sind und in die
drei monate reinfallen also da gibt es
noch ganz ganz viele ungeklärte fragen
die wir zunächst wirklich zügig
beantworten müssen weil er ärzte sitzen
vor ort und sollen den menschen diese
fragen beantworten und die haben sie
natürlich das nächste ist das thema mit
den angekauften das ist auch so ein
thema es ist einfach nicht gewertet wie
hoch die antikörper sind und ob es dann
sinn macht jemanden sofort wieder zum
pusten oder ob das vielleicht ein
problem darstellen könnte auch an das
thema müssen wir uns bringen dran machen
und möglichst schnell
das fahrzeug samt wurzelwerk coppenrath
di siena gibt sehr vielfältig nur
manchmal habe ich das gefühl die
praktiker fehlen da vor ort weil das mit
dem testen funktioniert er
offensichtlich nach wie vor nicht bei
uns in deutschland ja da höre ich
natürlich eine menge frustration auswahl
nachvollziehbar wenn man eben in der
praxis arbeitet unter täglich daneben
auch mit fragen konfrontiert wird und
ich bin mir relativ sicher dass diese
form auch sozusagen der selbstkritik
auch heute auf dieser veranstaltung in
gewisser weise jedenfalls auch ja doch
vorkam und dass man sich doch die frage
stellt ob das so glücklich war diesen
genesenen status so schnell zu ändern
bzw die regeln dazu ich glaube da hat es
ja auch dann viel kritik gegeben auch an
dieser entscheidung und wenn wir das
jetzt von frau dieckmann auch so richtig
eingeordnet bekommen haben bzw steht ja
auch so in den beschluss das soll sich
ja so auch nicht wiederholen so kann sie
das vielleicht ein bisschen trösten oder
nicht
hören sie mich noch
da war sie weg
offenbar haben wir den kontakt
abgebrochen das war jetzt aber kein
böser wille von uns das kann manchmal
passieren wir bitten das zu
entschuldigen ich wünsche trotzdem alles
gute an doktor lisa federle danke auch
dass sie noch mal für uns zur verfügung
stand wir haben einige fragen und
kommentare vorlesen können wir sind
inzwischen bei stattlichen zwei stunden
angekommen ich danke ganz herzlich für
die aufmerksamkeit und wünsche euch noch
einen schönen abend und bis zum nächsten
mal macht's gut